COVERT EMERGENCY IN TO PROTECT
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE THE SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE. HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE OR ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE ONE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE FOR OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SURE WAY.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE UN MUTED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE. THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST. MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. FIFTY
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS AND CENTER OF THE
COMMITTEE WANTS TO TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY EACH
SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO WAS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN IS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
TIME LAGS FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW. USE
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. MAY BE
HEARD. WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS
ON TODAY'S AGENDA FIVE MEASURES
HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM TODAY'S
AGENDA ITEM TO SB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT ITEM FIVE S. B. FOUR
SEVENTY ONE ITEMS SEVEN SB
THREE TWENTY FOUR ITEM ELEVEN
SB FIVE EIGHT FIVE AND ITEM
THIRTEEN S. B. TWO TWO FIVE.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON
THE BILLS LET'S SEE ONE. HI.
ELLIPSIS. ONE SECOND PLEASE.
NOW LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROCK HERE
ROCK HERE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES
HERE ARCHULETA. ARGILLITE HERE
BEAT BECKER BAKER HERE DODD
EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE HER TADO
JONES LEYVA MEN. MANY HERE
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HERE A SHOW A
BOGUS HANNAH. WE'RE ABSOLUTE
QUORUM HOWEVER WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND PROCEED CENTER BRADFORD YOU
HAVE ONE BUILDER PRESENT TODAY
SENATE BILL SIX OH THREE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT SIX OH THREE
AND IT'S JUST A- BILL THAT
HOPES ADDRESS A PROBLEM THAT
EXIST IN THE CANNABIS. INDUSTRY
AS IT RELATES TO. EQUITY
ACCESSIBILITY. AND THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM OF
FUNDING FEE WAIVER AND DEFERRAL
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
I'VE FOUGHT THIRD IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED SB FIVE NINE
FIVE THE CREATED A FEE WAIVER
AND DEFERRAL PROGRAM TO HELP
THOSE BUSINESSES STRUGGLING TO
ENTER THE SPACE AS WE KNOW IT'S
COSTLY TO GET IN HIS FACE. BUT
I ALSO IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AUTHOR S. B. TWELVE NINETY FOUR
WHICH WERE CREATED TO SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAM THAT'S PROVIDED
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
GRANTS TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO. ENCOURAGE
MINORITY OWNED WOMEN OWNED AND
VETERAN OWNED BUSINESSES
STANDARD TO SPACE BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW THIS IS NOT ENOUGH TO HELP
EQUITY BECAUSE- BUSINESSES
BECAUSE OVERCOME DECADES OF
HARM INDICATED BY THE SO CALLED
WAR ON DRUGS- LOCAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS STILL NEED TO PAY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
IN FEES ALONE BEFORE THEY CAN
EVEN THINK ABOUT OPENING THEIR
DOORS HEARD FROM PLENTY OF MY
CONCERN WITH. THE BUSINESSES
WHO HAVE PAID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN LEASES
AND- SET UP EQUIPMENT AND ALL
THAT AND THEY STILL. DON'T HAVE
A LICENSE TO BEGIN SO. THOSE
FEES ARE IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
OTHER UPFRONT COSTS OF STARTING
A BUSINESS SUCH AS THIS. THAT'S
ENOUGH SO IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
AS I STATED I AUTHORED- SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE IT OUGHT TO BE
AUTHORIZED THE LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A DEFERRAL AND WAIVER
PROGRAM. FOR APPLICANTS
LICENSING AND RENEWAL FEES OF
EQUITY IN NEEDS BASED
APPLICANTS. ARE SALLY THIS PRO
WAS NOT IMPLEMENTED- AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR AS
INTENDED DO TO A LACK OF
RESOURCES. SB SIX OH THREE
RESPONSE TO THAT FAILURE BY
STOPPING TWO PATHWAYS TO
ACHIEVING THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF SB FIVE NINE FIVE.
THE FIRST IS IT REQUIRES
CANNABIS LICENSING AUTHORITIES
TO ESTABLISH THE FEE FOR
DEFERRAL AND WAIVER PROGRAM AND
SECOND IT IS DOLLARS THE TAX
CREDIT. FOR FEES PAID BY LOCAL
EQUITY APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES
BE WAIVERS AND DEFERRALS
DIRECTLY SUPPORT NEED BASED AND
EQUITY BUSINESSES. THEY ARE ONE
OF THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE TOOLS WE HAVE TO
MITIGATE TO SYSTEMIC INEQUALITY
AND RACISM THAT IS PERFECT
PERPETRATED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS.
THIS BILL AVANCES THE
CONVERSATION OF FEE RELIEF. FOR
EQUITY IN NEEDS BASED
APPLICANTS WHICH HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR MANY YEARS THIS IS A
LONG OVERDUE SOLUTION. TO THIS
ISSUE ND I ITS URGENT URGENTLY
NEEDED AND PROVEN BY- MANY
LOCAL EQUITY BUSINESSES WHO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE-
THAT BEING SAID I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND HERE
TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THIS
MEASURE IS ADAM SPIKER.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CELL
PHONE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION. THANK YOU SENATOR
MISTER SPEICHER PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR IN
SENATORS- GET MY NAME'S ADAM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COALITION.
FIRST OFF I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR BRADFORD. AUTHORING
THIS MEASURE AND OTHERS THAT
THE PAST FEW YEARS AS THE-
EXPLAINED. IT BASICALLY JUST
PROVIDING HELP FOR LOCAL SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS GIVING THEM.
MORE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FROM
THE STATE TO TRY TO HELP INSURE
SIX THAT. THE VERY MUCH OF.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THIRD-
COALITION WAS STARTED OVER FIVE
YEARS AGO TO COLLAPSE OLFACTION
YOU TO BE INDUSTRY IN LOS
ANGELES UNDER ONE UMBRELLA AND
WORK TOGETHER TO CREATE
CANNABIS REGULATION LICENSING
TAXATION ENFORCEMENT. AND
SOCIAL EQUITY IN THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES FOR THE FIRST TIME
WITH UNANIMOUS SUPPORT FROM THE
CITY COUNCIL AND A PUBLIC VOTE
MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. AT OVER EIGHTY
PERCENT. BUT WHILE THERE'S
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
IN LOS ANGELES THERE ARE
ALREADY MORE APPLICATIONS BEING
PROCESSED UNDER THE SOCIAL
EQUITY PROGRAM. THAN ANYWHERE
ELSE IN THE COUNTRY. ALL PROP
SIXTY. AND THEN CREATING
BALCARCE WERE GROUNDBREAKING
MILESTONES FOR LEGAL CANNABIS
TO CALIFORNIA. THERE'D BEEN
MANY PROBLEMS LEFT UNADDRESSED
THAT AFFECT THE OVERALL HEALTH
OF THE LEGAL INDUSTRY THE
ABILITY FOR LICENSE HOLDERS TO
COMPETE AGAINST THE ILLICIT
MARKET. HIGH TAXES AND
REGULATORY COSTS THE LEGAL
OPERATOR FOLLOWED IN THE
ILLICIT IGNORES. AND FINALLY
THE ROLL OUT AND SUPPORT FOR
SOCIAL EQUITY PROGRAMS AND THE
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS. TRYING TO
GET THROUGH THESE PROGRAMS
AROUND THE STATE. FOR
ADDITIONAL CONTACTS OVER 50% OF
LOCAL AND STATE APPLICATION
APPLICATIONS FOR CANNABIS
LICENSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NEVER EVEN END UP
GETTING OPEN FOR BUSINESS. I
BRING THIS UP BECAUSE THE WAY
THE BILLS DRAFTED IF WE CAN GET
THE SOCIAL EQUITY APPLICANTS
LICENSE OPEN FOR BUSINESS AND
PAYING TAXES. ONLY THEN WILL
THE TAX WRITE OFF COMPONENT BE
APPLICABLE. GIVEN THE CURRENT
STATE OF THE LEGAL INDUSTRY IN
THE STATE. IT IS UNFORTUNATELY
NOT A CERTAINTY. THAT SOCIAL
EQUITY LICENSES WILL GET TO THE
POINT WHERE THEY CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF THE RELIEF THIS
BILL CAN PROVIDE. UNFORTUNATELY
NO SILVER BULLET TO FIXING ALL
THE ISSUES THE LEGAL CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FACES TODAY AND THE
CHALLENGES SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS GO THROUGH TO TRY TO
GET A LICENSE. TO GET OPEN BEEN
COMPETE IN A STILL HEAVILY
ILLICIT MARKETPLACE BUT SENATOR
BRAD BIRD'S SB SIX OH THREE THE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
THAT IS NEEDED IMMEDIATELY- A
LAUNDRY LIST ABOUT THE FRONT
COST THANK YOU SENATOR PRODUCT.
THAT IS EQUITY. HAS TO INCUR
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN OPEN THEIR
DOORS FOR BUSINESS. SECURING
PROPERTY. GETTING LEGAL ADVICE
APPLICATION WRITING BUILD OUT
COSTS. GETTING INVENTORY HIRING
STAFF. AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT
LOCAL AND STATE LICENSING FEES
JUST TO NAME A FEW MOST OF
THESE COSTS CAN'T EVEN BE
WRITTEN OFF LIKE A NORMAL
BUSINESS COULD BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL STANCE ON CANNABIS ANY
PARTICULAR TO EIGHTY EACH. WITH
THE IRS I WOULD ARGUE THE
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED IN SB SIX
OH THREE WILL HELP MORE
BUSINESSES ACTUALLY GET OPEN
START MAKING LEGAL CELL AND
START PAYING LOCAL AND STATE
TAXES. WHERE THE REBATE FROM
SIX THIRTY SIX OH THREE WOULD
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE EACH YEAR.
EXCEPT FOR WILL ALLOW SOCIAL I
APPLE AND LYFT IN COLDER TO
WRITE OFF THEIR AND STATE THESE.
WHICH CAN BE AT LEAST TEN OF
THE BALCONY OF DOLLARS IT'S NOT
GOING INTO THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP.
MISTER SHARON SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
IN FAVOR. OF SB SIX OH THREE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NONE OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SIX OH THREE. I
SEE NONE WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT TO ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL SIX ZERO THREE
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SIX ZERO THREE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE WILL
NOW GO TO LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIND SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SURE JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE GOING TO GO TO
LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS ANNE FRANK THOUGH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD.
YOUR MUSIC ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE-
I'M. THIRTY FIVE. ONE THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE
ARMSTRONG SPEAKING AS AN
INDIVIDUAL FIFTEEN YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN CANNABIS POLICY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. BY
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS IS AMBER MARC WITH NOR
CAL CANNABIS COMPANY WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. MISTER CHAIR THERE IS
NO ONE ELSE WOULD SIGNAL BUT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORTERS WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. FURTHER ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NONE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL SIX ZERO THREE.
I SEE NONE. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE THE SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY HELLO
THANK YOU TO OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOT BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS. MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THE. THANK YOU WAVE YOUR HAND
PLEASE. SENATOR NEWMAN I TELL
YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND THE AUTHORED BY YOU
HAVE TRULY BEEN A LEADER ON
ISSUES AROUND EQUITY EVER SINCE
THE LEGALIZATION OF
RECREATIONAL CANNABIS- AND I
COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR CURRENT
EFFORTS AND DO IT WHEN THE TIME
TO PROBE LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
CENTER BRADFORD BEFORE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AS STATED I THINK THIS IS
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE AS WE-KNOW WE PASSED. PROP SIXTY FOUR
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WITH
THE HOPES THAT. THE LEGALIZE
MARKET FOR DON'T USE WOULD. BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL THOSE WHO
CHOSE TO SEE DOCTOR WERNER
OPPORTUNITIES HERE. BUT
UNFORTUNATE ALLOWS FOREIGN
AFTER YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT
THERE ARE MANY. ROADBLOCKS MANY
OF THEM FINANCIAL EVEN FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE THE BUSINESS
ACCU MEN. AND EXPERTISE TO GET
GOING MANY OF THE FINANCIAL
BURDENS ARE JUST. OF
PREVENTING- THIS INDUSTRY FROM
TRULY TAKING OFF AND THAT'S WHY
WE'VE SEEN A GROWTH IN THE
LISTED MARKET MORE SO THAN A
BURDENSOME BURGEONING GROWTH.
IN THE LEGAL MARKET THIS BILL
JUST SIMPLY HELPS THOSE
BUSINESSES. ALL HAVE A FEE
WAIVER OR DEFERRAL TO HELP THEM
ENTER BECAUSE AS STATED IT'S
THOUSANDS IF NOT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF START
UP COSTS. JUST TO ENTER THIS
MARKET AND SO BY A LEVY A LEVY
EIGHTEEN. BILLS FEES ARE
DEFERRING THOSE FEES THROUGH A
DEFERRAL OR A TAX CREDIT WILL
GREATLY AID OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS SPECIALLY THOSE
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
THE MOST. BY THE WAR ON DRUGS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
LET'S. ESTABLISH A QUORUM NOW.
PAN YOU CAN HEAR. WE HAVE A
QUORUM DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO THREE
MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
REMIND YOU TO PLEASE HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FILE ITEM ONE
SENATE BILL SIX ZERO THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IN A RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE RALPH HI. RALPH HI
MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA I. URGE A
LOT I BEAT BAKER BY BAKER AYE
DODD EGGMAN RIGHT EGGMAN AYE
HER TADO JONES LEYVA MEN FIVE
MILLION HI NEWMAN HI NEWMAN AYE
THAT SHOW ABODE HAN HI CAN I.
THE BILL HAS SEVEN BOATS WILL
HOLD ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS. WELCOME CENTER
CABALLERO YOU HAVE TWO BILLS
TODAY. YOUR FIRST MEASURE IS
SENATE BILL.
FIFTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FIFTY NINE WHICH ENSURES
THAT EXISTING LICENSED CANNABIS
OPERATORS WILL CONTINUE TO
LEGALLY OPERATE THEIR
BUSINESSES OTHER APPLICATIONS
FOR THE ANNUAL LICENSURE ARE
BEING EVALUATED SPECIFICALLY SB
FIFTY NINE EXTENDS THE REPEAL
DATE OF THE CANNABIS
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM BY
SIX YEARS. THIS IS A CRUCIAL
CRITICAL PRIORITY FOR THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ABSENT THIS
EXTENSION OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
CANNABIS LICENSEES WOULD BE
FORCED TO SHUTTER OPERATIONS
WHEN THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PROGRAM EXPIRES AT THE END OF
THIS YEAR ACCORDING TO A RECENT
REPORT 83% OF CANNABIS LICENSES
WERE PROVISIONAL AS OF MARCH.
FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHILE
ONLY SEVENTEEN WERE ANNUAL
LICENSES SB FIFTY NINE WILL
AUTHORIZE THE STATE LICENSING
ENTITIES TO CONTINUE TO REVIEW
PROVISIONAL LICENSES UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT SO THAT AFTER COVERED THE
COVERT NINETEEN VIRUS
RESTRICTIONS. ON TRAVEL OR
LIFTED THE FIELD INSPECTIONS
AND THE PUBLIC MEETINGS CAN
RESUME. SB FIFTY NINE MEETS THE
SPIRIT AND THE INTENT OF THE
ORIGINAL LEGISLATION WHICH
DEVELOPED THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSE PROGRAM TO PROVIDE A
STABLE RELIABLE PACKED FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INTEREST
INDUSTRY TO MAINTAIN OPERATIONS
WHILE TRANSITIONING. INTO THE
NEWLY REGULATED MARKET. FROM
BIG SUR TO MENDOCINO COUNTY
THERE CALIFORNIANS STILL
WAITING TO RECEIVE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES AND IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR THE INDUSTRY TO CAPTURE AS
MANY LEGAL ENTRANCE AS IT CAN.
SB FIFTY NINE ALSO HELPS
ACHIEVE A KEY POLITICAL POLICY
OBJECTIVE TO REDUCE THE UPFRONT
CAPITAL EXPENDITURES NEEDED TO
ENTER THE INDUSTRY ALLOWING
SMALL BUSINESS OPERATORS THE
TIME TO BUILD CAPITAL NEEDED TO
MOVE INTO THE ANNUAL LICENSING
STRUCTURE. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIFTY NINE ARE AMY
JENKINS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND KRISTEN. NEVER
DAHLE OF THE INTERNATIONAL CAN
CANNABIS FARMERS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR WITNESSES- PLEASE
BE MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
LIMITATION. FIRST AMY JENKINS
PLEASE PROCEED. YES THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND I WILL ACTUALLY BE
COVERING FOR GO CORRECT AND-
AND MYSELF SPOKE AGAIN AMY
JENKINS WITH PRECISION ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CODE. THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND THE
INTERNATIONAL CANNABIS FARMERS
ASSOCIATION BOTH ORGANIZATIONS
COLLECTIVELY REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
MEMBERS ACROSS ALL ASPECTS OF
THE CANNABIS SUPPLY CHAIN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THE CRITICAL
LEGISLATION AND FOR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL AND
COMPREHENSIVE AND NOW WITH
THAT. LAST YEAR CALIFORNIA'S
LEGAL CANNABIS INDUSTRY
GENERATED THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN CANADA SALES
EMPLOYED FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FULL
TIME WORKERS UP BY ALMOST
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND GENERATED
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
REVENUE FOR THE STATE DESPITE
THE INDUSTRY WOULD YES THEY
CONTRIBUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY THE LEGAL INDUSTRY. A
PENDING CRISIS. PUT IT BLUNTLY
WHAT POLITICS. OF THE PERSON
LIKE PROGRAM AS THE FINAL IN
THE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY TWO
HUNDRED EXISTING PROVISION LIFE.
ARE AT RISK OF FALLING OUT OF
COULD. WITH THE STATE'S
REQUIREMENTS WHEN THE PROGRAM
EXPIRES ON JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY Q. CATIONS WITH THE MANY
OF YOU AND YOUR STAFF I'VE BEEN
FREQUENTLY ASKED WHY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER A
THIRD EXTENSION OF THE PROGRAM
WHICH WAS BY DESIGN ONE HUNDRED
TO BE TEMPORARY. LIKE MANY
ISSUES INVOLVING CANADA THE
ANSWER IS COMPLICATED. UNDER
EXISTING LAW APPLICANTS FOR
PROVISIONAL LICENSE MUST
DEMONSTRATE THAT THEY ARE A
LOOK ONLY AUTHORIZED TO ENGAGE
IN THE COMMERCIAL CANNABIS
ACTIVITY THANKS FOR THE LIFE
REPAIR CRYING FOR. AND BE ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO ACHIEVE
FULL ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE.
ONLY WHEN THE APPLICATION
PROCESS IS INCOMPLETE CAN A
CANNABIS OPERATOR MOVE OUT OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSE STATUS. AND
RECEIVE AN ANNUAL. LICENSE FROM
THE STATE. YEAH UNLIKE MY OF
THE WORLD HOW. CANNABIS
BUSINESSES ARE STILL TO MARKET.
UNBOUND REVIEW. AFTER OF WHERE
THE BUSINESS THE BLOKE. WHETHER
OR NOT THE APPLICANT PREPARE TO
PERFORM COUNCILMAN. TO THE
PROMISE. OR WHETHER THE
COMPOSER. YET CULTIVATION
RETAIL MANUFACTURING%
EXPECTORANT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
EXISTING GENERAL PLAN. INSTEAD
EVERY APPLICANT MUST UNDERGO A
FIGHT REPUBLICAN ALYSA THIS IS
A PROVEN TO BE INCREDIBLY TIME
CONSUMING BOTH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FROM CANNABIS
OPERATORS. AS WELL AS FOR THE
STATE LICENSING AUTHORITIES
WHICH ARE CATHOLIC REVIEWING
APPLICATIONS FOR COMPLETE. WITH
YOUR EXTENSION OF A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE PROGRAM AS PROPOSED IN
THE CELL WILL ENSURE THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS AS WELL AS THE
STATE OPPOSITION TRYING TO
COMPLETE APPLICATION REVIEW. AN
INCH FOR SURE FULL ENVIRONMENT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE CHIEF.
SB FIFTY NINE WILL ALSO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED CERTAINTY FOR LEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATORS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY AT RISK OF BEING A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE THAT THE
FIRE WHILE THEIR APPLICATIONS
ARE PENDING FINAL REVIEW AND
APPROVAL. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
PLEASE SUPPORT AFTER FIFTY NINE
TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU MS JENKINS WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY. SEEING NONE
LET'S CHECK WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE AGREES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE. BILL FIFTY
NINE I SEE NONE. WELL NOW MOVES
TO. WAITING TO. VIA THE TELL.
OF US MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PROMPT THOSE. WAITING TO TEST
IN SOME OF BILL FIFTY NINE WE
WILL BEGIN. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
PARDON ME JUST A MOMENT. ON THE
OTHER LINE TWENTY. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY DOES ON BEHALF OF
CRESCO LABS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. NORTH WIND. THREE GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
ORIGINS COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THE ORIGINS COUNCIL
THE PRODUCT OF OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS THE TRINITY COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL ALLIANCE THE
MENDOCINO CANNABIS ALLIANCE
SONOMA COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE
NEVADA COUNTY CANNABIS ALLIANCE
AND THE BIG SUR FARMERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE FORWARD.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. HOW FINE
FOR ONE. GOOD MORNING MADELINE
COOPER FROM NIELSEN MARKS WERE
ON BEHALF OF YELLOW COUNTY AND
FORT THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT- LINE IS OPEN. VANDERMARK
WITH MARKUP IN THE COMPANY WITH
THE PORTABLE. THANK YOU THANKS
PLEASE. LINE. TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A MESSAGE
FROM THE CISNEROS FIRM WHICH
ALSO DOES BUSINESS AS THE
CANNABIS CORPORATE LAW FIRMS MY
FIRM- I'M REPRESENTS ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY SINCE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MISTAKE AND-
AND INDICATE STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL HOWEVER I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THE LACK OF DUE
PROCESS THAT'S BE STOWED IN
THIS BILL- AS IN THE ORIGINAL
ENACTMENT I'VE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN CORRESPONDENCE IN THE
SAME BAND- BUT PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
THEIR RIGHT AND THEIR
LIVELIHOOD. AND SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO FORFEIT THEIR RIGHTS WHEN
THEY LACK CONTROL OVER THE
PROCESS- INTENTIONAL
SUPPRESSION DUE PROCESS IS THE
OPPOSITE OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DEMOCRACY IT WAS I WAS
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE DUE
PROCESS THE CONSIDERATION WAS
NOT MADE- IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S REPORT AND I WOULD
REQUEST THAT YOU CONSIDER
WHETHER OR NOT YOU PROCESSES
PROPERLY AFFORDED TO THESE
ATKINS UNDER PROVISIONAL SYSTEM
UNDER WHICH THEY HAVE NO
CONTROL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS PLEASE. PINE FORTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE EASE AND THE CAT
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL FIFTY
NINE THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE.
LINE. FIFTY ONE. THE REQUESTED
CERTAIN VALUE FOR THE CLIENTS
ORDER SO. THANK YOU NEXT. SURE
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON
WHO'S QUEUED UP THE SPEED JUST
A MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU. LINE.
FORTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THIS TRACY
STEVENS ON BEHALF OF MATURE UP
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND ALSO
BODY AND MIND IN LONG BEACH
AND- THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. PINE
FIFTY THREE. JERRY MEMBERS RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF CMG KHALIFA
BASED OUT OF SAN JOSE AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL PUBLIC BUILDINGS ARE
JONES SAWYER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE- WHOSE SIGNALED THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH
WHAT THIS IS IN THE GALLERY AND
I SEE NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL
FIFTY NINE I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THAT ROOM. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OF US IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WILL PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WITH
MODERATOR WAITING TO TESTIFY WE
WILL BEGIN. FOR ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY- IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL NOW GO TO LINE SIXTEEN
LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TAYLOR RUSSIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU ACTUALLY
IT'S A TRAINER WE HAVE A
CONCERN THAT I THINK WHICH ARE
CALCULATED IN THE NOW OFFICE-
OUR FARMERS YOU KNOW PROBABLY
BETTER THAN MOST UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MANAGING PEOPLE COMPLIANCE. AND
BUT WE AND CERTAINLY AN
EXTENSION OF THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES OF WARRANTED BUT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LENGTH. OF
THE EXTENSION GIVEN THAT
PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION FOR SEE
QUITE DURING THAT TIME PERIOD
BURKE WE'RE JUST CONCERNED THAT
OPENED FIRE MENTAL AND
COMMUNITY IMPACT WILL PERCENT
FOR WHAT WOULD BE TWELVE YEARS
WITH YOUR ORIGINAL LIKE TO KEEP
OUR WE'RE WORKING HARD WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR AGAIN WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION.
HOPEFULLY TO THE FILM REPORT.
WE CAN FIND RESOLUTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BURGER NEXT.
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE L.
TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
LET'S NOT TAKE THE DISCUSSION
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PAN. YOU CAN SHARE- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS- THIRD
SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS PROPER THE
FARM BUREAU CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND WHY
WE NEED AN EXTENSION DISCUSS
WITH CODED AND- SOME OF THE-
TIME IT'S BEEN TAKING TO. GET
THROUGH THE LICENCES BY TWENTY-
THANK YOU TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE ON THE
LONG SIDE- PERHAPS THE AUTHOR
COULD ADDRESS THE ISSUES ARE
BROUGHT BY THE FARM BUREAU AND
ADDRESS THE LENGTH OF. HOW LONG
THE EXTENSION IS UP- DON'T BE
GREAT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND DOCTRINE FOR THAT QUESTION-
THERE THE IDENTIFICATION OF SIX
YEARS WAS TO GIVE US- WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP THIS
BILL REALLY SIMPLE IT'S JUST AN
EXTENSION- AND- IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME BACK AND MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS TO HOW WE DO THE
LICENSING BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR
HAS- PROPOSED IN HIS BUDGET.
THE REORGANIZATION OF THE THREE
ENTITIES RIGHT NOW THAT DO THE
LICENSING INTO ONE LICENSE-
ENTITY AND ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
THESE- SEQUOIA THE SEQUOIA-
PROCESS IS IT IT REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE THE LEAD
AGENCY AND SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVEN'T
REALLY MOVED AT LIKE THEY
SHOULD AND IT MAY BE POSSIBLE
THAT WE'LL HAVE TO LOOK AT
ANOTHER ALTERNATIVE TO HOW WE
GET SEEK A- A PROCESS HE'S
GOING AND GET THEM DONE IN IN A
IN A EXPEDITIOUS MANNER SO THE
SIX YEARS GIVES US OUR HORIZON
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT THAT. AND
TO FIGURE OUT IN WHICH
DIRECTION WE WANT TO GO AND-
AND OBVIOUSLY WHAT WE WANT IS
AS MANY PEOPLE LICENSE ANNUALLY
AS POSSIBLE- THE IDEA IS NOT TO
STRING IT OUT BUT TO GET IT
DONE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT
THERE'S A THERE ARE A LOT O
MOVING PARTS AS TO WHY IT
HASN'T HAPPENED UP TO THIS TIME
AND WE DON'T. WANT TO LOSE. THE
LEGAL MARKET. AND IF I COULD I
AM FINE AND- WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT THIS DOESN'T
SANCTION ILLEGAL GROWS WE CAN
STILL GO AFTER THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT. CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN ILLEGAL GROWS. THIS
THIS REALLY HAS TO DO WITH THE
LEGAL MARKET. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAM YEAH NO I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER- I THINK I PERSONALLY
PREFER A SHORTER TIME AND MAYBE
IS THAT THE BILL MOVES ON AND
THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAPPENED WILL
HAVE A BETTER DEFINITION OF.
HOW LONG IT IS ACTUALLY
NECESSARY- SO I REALIZE MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT GAS GIVING ALL THE
MOVING PARTS. SO I'D BE HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL AT THIS POINT
IN TIME FOR YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS- SO WE CAN TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AND APPRECIATE THE
ANSWER THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
PAN COLLEAGUES ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE CENTER COVER YOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
AS I SAID WE'RE DEALING WITH%
THE LEGAL CANNABIS MARKET- AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BYE
BODE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
PAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MEMBERS PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FILE ITEM THREE
SENATE BILL FIFTY NINE YOU PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ROTH
FIVE ROSS HI MELENDEZ ARCHULETA
HI OCALAN IV BAKER. HI BACKER
AYE DODD I THOUGHT I EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN HER TADO. JONES LEYVA
MEN FIVE MILLION HI NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN AYE IT SHOW ABOUT OKAY
I'M A SHOW GUY HI CAN I. BILL
NINE VOTES TO GET OUT BUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
CABALLERO THANK YOU YOU HAVE-
ANOTHER BILL ONE MORE BILL SB
SIX TWO FIVE. YES MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE THE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM. AS
YOU AS YOU MAY KNOW MANY
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA LACKED THE FINANCIAL
SERVICES AND INVESTMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT PROMOTE
SUSTAINABLE AND COMMUNITY BASED
ECONOMIC GROWTH. SIGNIFIES FILL
THIS GAP THEY ARE COMMUNITY
BASED FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
THAT PROMOTE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO THE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AFFORDABLE LENDING AND
OTHER FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
FUND SERVED OR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO HELP THEM JOIN
THE ECONOMIC MAINSTREAM.
ACCORDING TO THIS CDFI
COALITION THERE ARE
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED CDFI
IS HEADQUARTERED IN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGH THEIR WORK AND THAT
OF OTHER CDFI IS OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CDFI INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
PROVIDED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUSINESSES.
OVER A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION TO COMMUNITY NONPROFITS
CONSTRUCTED AND REHABILITATED
OVER THREE MILLION SQUARE FEET
OF REAL ESTATE AND BUILT ALMOST
FOUR THOUSAND UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE STATE
IS ALSO WORKED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH CEDIA FIGHTS IN THE PAST
THROUGH THE COIN PROGRAM AND
THE GOLDEN STATE ACQUISITION
FUND WHICH PROVIDED RESOURCES
VERY VALUABLE RESOURCES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. MORE RECENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA CDFI NETWORK WHICH
TAP AGAIN TO HELP DISTRIBUTE
DISTRIBUTE OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN DIRECT FUNDING FROM
THE STATE TO PROVIDE SMALL
BUSINESS. TENANTS AND LANDLORDS
FINANCIAL REAP RELIEF AS A
RESULT OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
BROUGHT ON BY THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE IS A SIMPLE BILL
THAT WILL HELP SEAT CDFI IS
CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. TO CREATE A
PERMANENT FINANCING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO ALLOCATE
GRANT FUNDS WHEN APPROPRIATED
BY THE STATE SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
INVESTMENT IN INNOVATION
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT BREAK
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE I. BANK
TO PROVIDE GRANTS TO QUALIFYING
CDFI. ELIGE YOUR BILL CDFI SOME
MUST HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF AND
IN. AND MISUSED ANYFUNDING
PROVIDED THROUGH THE GRANT
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE LOANS GRANTS
EQUITY INVESTMENTS FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL AND HELP ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. IS MICHAEL CARROLL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MISTER CARROLL YOU MAY PROCEED
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
LIMITATIONS. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN LAWSON MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM MICHAEL
CARROLL IN THE LENDING DIRECTOR
FOR THE LIBERAL PROGRAM AT
LOCAL INITIATIVES SUPPORT
CORPORATION. A NATIONAL STUDIO
BY THIS VERY ACTIVE YOUR
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER TODAY I'M
HERE REPRESENTING. CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT WHICH IS AN EMERGING
NETWORK OF OVER THIRTY LARGE
INSTALL CYDIA BY. WORKING IN
THE STATE. OUR COALITION IS CO
SPONSOR OF SB SIX TWENTY FIVE
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
CAFIERO. SHIP IN ORDERING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. BILL
REPRESENTS A GROWING
RECOGNITION OF BY THE PUBLIC
SECTOR SIGNIFIES CAN BE
PARTNERS AND PROVIDING MUCH
NEEDED CAPITAL AND RESOURCES TO
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. IT IS
MODELED AFTER THE VERY
SUCCESSFUL BUT OVERSUBSCRIBED
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD FEDERAL
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED BY THE US
TREASURY DEPARTMENT. AS SUCH IT
WOULD PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED CAN
FLEXIBLE CAPITAL TO SIGNIFIES
TO MAKE LOANS AND ACCOMPANYING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SMALL
BUSINESSES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS. CONSUMERS AND EVEN
LOCA COMMUNITIES ADDRESSING
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
LIKE SAFE DRINKING WATER
SYSTEMS. WHAT KINDS OF PROJECTS
WILL GET CAPITAL FOR THIS
PROGRAM. FOR EXAMPLE INCLUDE
DEVELOP LOANS WILL ALLOW NOT
FROM DEVELOPERS TO ACQUIRE AND
PREPARE LAND FOR MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. EARLY
STAGES. OF THE ASSEMBLE
RESOURCES ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT HOUSING COMMITTEE
DEVELOPMENT AND LOW INCOME-HOUSING TAX CREDITS FOR THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
TO SURVIVE IMPACTS OF THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC. OUR MEMBERS
ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT SMALL
MINORITY LED BUSINESSES HAD IN
OBTAINING DISASTER ASSISTANCE.
PROGRAMS LIKE THE S. B. EIGHT
THEY WERE ALL PROTECTION
PROGRAM. WE OFFER SMALL LOANS
TO THOSE THAT DIDN'T FIT THE
PROFILE OF TRADITIONAL
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. SOME OF
OUR MEMBERS MAKE SMALL CONSUMER
LOANS HELLO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ALLOWING THEM TO
ESCAPE. FOUR AVOID THAT TRAP OF
PAYDAY LENDERS. US SENATOR
CAFIERO POINTED OUT SHE ADVISE
OF ALREADY PROVEN TO BE GOOD
PARTNERS WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. CONCLUDING
INCLUDING THE GOLDEN STATE
ACQUISITIONS ON. AND BY MY
ORGANIZATIONS RECENT
PARTNERSHIP WITH H. U. D. RIGHT
TO POTENTIAL APPLICANTS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CODE RENTAL RELIEF
PROGRAM. I REALIZE THAT MY TIME
IS SHORT HERE SO I WOULD LIKE
TO CONCLUDE BY URGING A VOTE
FOR SB TWENTY FIVE. MINS THANK
YOU FOR TAKING UP THIS ISSUE IN
A VERY THOUGHTFUL MANNER THANK
YOU MISTER CARROLL LET'S MOVE
TO WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
SUCH WITNESSES. WHETHER ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL SIX TWO FIVE.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
THIS MDERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SENATE BILL. SIX TWO FIVE WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE OF
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT. JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT MISTER CHECKLIST
THANK YOU. YOU WILL NOW GO TO
LINE FIFTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS FEELING BETTER AND
DINNER POLICY ADVOCATE AT THE
ON PUBLIC YOU'D BOND MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES FUND INCLUDING
ARCADIA BY LANDING ON ARM
OPPORTUNITY ON COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WORK TO CREATE AN
INCLUSIVE. HEALTHY FINANCIAL.
HOW SMALL BIT ON OUR- BY
CONNECTING ON TO PUT OF BORDER
OKAY. EDUCATION INFO COACHING
AND THAT'S WHAT. SUPPORT AT THE
TWENTY FIVE WE HAVE MADE IT
NINE THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY HELLO MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND NINETY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. LAST
FISCAL YEAR HE MADE NEARLY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A TOTAL OF
MORE THAN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
SB SIX. FIVE FULL ABOUT BEING
AT WORK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. NOW GO. TO FORTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRED
MEMBERS PRIOR TO GUEST- ON
BEHALF OF THE BEAUTY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWELVE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL. SIX TWO FIVE.
SEEING NO WITNESSES LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD ONCE
AGAIN. PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL SIX
TWO FIVE WE WILL PROCEED. FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL SIX TWO
FIVE. S. ONE ZERO PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU SIR. LET'S
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. I SEE
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA CENTER
ANGELA YOU HAVE THE FLOOR YES
THANK YOU MEASURE I'D LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR FOR HER
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL SENATE
BILL SIX TWO FIVE IT OBVIOUSLY
IS A JUMPSTART- FOR STRUGGLING
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. FOR PARTNERSHIPS-
SO MANY COMMUNITIES NOW THAT
ARE COMING FORWARD AND WE
REALIZE THE PHYSICAL IMPACT
FINANCIAL IMPACT THAT IS
AFFECTED ALL OF THEM BECAUSE OF
THE- CORONAVIRUS. AND
ECONOMICALLY I THINK THIS WILL
BE A GREAT PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
I. BANKING COMMUNITIES SHOW I
ASKED WE MOVE IT. THANK YOU
MEASURE THANK YOU SENATOR
MEMBERS ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS AND
VANISHER MIKE UP FOR A REASON.
APPARENTLY APPARENTLY NOT GOOD
SIR ROSSITER BECKER PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IT A BIG FANTASY ADVICE
INCLUDING OPPORTUNITY FUND
WHICH TESTIFIED AS SHOULD BE
CLEAR THE MONEY CAN BE USED
THERE'S A PACIFIC MANSION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT ONE POINT
BUT THIS MONEY COULD BE USED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS THAT'S
CORRECT IT'S PRETTY BROAD RIGHT
NOW- AND- YOU KNOW AS IT
PROCEEDS I EXPECT IT WILL WILL
MERIT A LITTLE BIT BUT MY
INTEREST I'M QUITE FRANKLY IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. CLINICS AND
MEDICAL FACILITIES- THERE IS
BEEN A- THERE IS A JOB. FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE TRAINED- AND IN
EUROPE CALIFORNIA THIS WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL AS WELL AS AT
BUSINESS REVITALIZATION
COMMUNITY REVITALIZATION. WE
GOT RID OF- OF- AT
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES IT YET
THERE ARE SOME. FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THAT
NEED TO BE MADE IN
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WOULD
REALLY HELP AND MANY OTHER-
POOR COMMUNITIES. YEAH I THINK
IT'S CRITICAL I ALSO DO THINK
THE SMALL BUSINESS LOAN PIECE.
ESPECIALLY FOR- BUT BUSINESS OF
COLOR THAT DON'T HAVE ACCESS
YOUR TIONAL FORMS A CAPITAL
THAT CAN FIND THOSE THAT
CAPITAL FROM C. DEFIES. IT'S
ALSO SUPER IMPORTANT SO BE
VOTING I APPRECIATE THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER BACKERS. I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR
THIS BILL- AND ECHOD CENTER
BAKER'S COMMENTS. THIS IS A
COMMUNITY AND DEMOGRAPHIC THAT
IS FAR TOO OFTEN UNDERSERVED
IT'S- HISTORICALLY BEEN A HUGE
PROBLEM- I CAME FOR A BANKING
POLICY BACKGROUND AND HOW TO
DEAL WITH THESE TRADITIONALLY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES OFTEN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- OFTEN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES HAS BEEN. A
SORE SPOT IN AN- EQUITABLE
BANKING HOUSING POLICIES FOR
MANY DECADES NOW AND SO. I
APPLAUD YOU FOR TAKING
LEADERSHIP HERE AND WOULD ASK
TO BE CO AUTHOR. AT THE
EARLIEST OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS CAN OR CONCERNS. I
SEE NO MIKE'S UP SO. SENATE
CAREER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS AND- ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE TASKS THAT I UNDERTAKE
UNDERTOOK IN THE DISTRICT IS TO
GO AND TALK TO SMALL BUSINESSES
ABOUT THE GRANT PROGRAM THAT.
THAT DOUBT THAT IT HAS
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY IN
IT BUT WHAT THEIR NUMBER ONE
REQUEST WHICH WAS RESOURCES TO
BE ABLE TO FIX UP THEIR
BUSINESSES IN THIS THIS FALLS
RIGHT IN LINE. WITH WITH WHAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THEIR ACCESS TO CAPITAL IS VERY
LIMITED SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY CENTER MEN LET'S GIVE
CENTER MINUTE CHANCE CENTER
MINUTES MOVE THE BILL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM FOR SENATE BILL
SIX Q. FIVE DEEP HOUSING RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE SO I CAN HEAR YOUR
VOTES. RALPH HI RALPH I
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BEAT. BECKER BAKER AYE DODD.
DODD AYE EGGMAN HI EGGMAN HI
HER TADO JONES HI JONES I LEYVA
IN. MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN AYE
AYE CHAU ABODE ON THE TURBO GUY
PAN HI CAN I. BILL HAS ELEVEN
SUFFICIENT TO GET OUT WILL HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER JONES
YOU HAVE ONE BILL TO PRESENT
TODAY SENATE BILL FIVE THREE
FOUR YOU MAY PROCEED. IRAQ
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR
UPDATES THE DENTAL HYGIENE FOR-
PRACTICE ACT INCLUDING UPDATING
THE BOARD MEMBERS TERMS TO MAKE
SURE THE WHOLE BOARD DOES NOT
TURN OUT IN JONES I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE LIVE.
THE BETTER PERFECT IF IT STAYS
PUT. WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO START
OVER. WHATEVER YOU PREFER I'LL
JUST GO WITH MY LAST PARAGRAPH
YOUR MISTER CHAIR LIKE TO
DEFERRED THE TIME- TO THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. ON THE
WITNESS LINE ANTHONY LONG FROM
THE DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA AND JENNIFER
TANNAHILL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL HYGIENISTS
ASSOCIATION THEY WILL GIVE A
MUCH MORE FIFTY AN ACCURATE-
TESTIMONY TOWARDS THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MR LLAMAS
JANET HILL YOU MAY PROCEED
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
LIMITATIONS. GERMAN ROTTEN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M ANTHONY
LAMB THEY COULD HAVE OFFICER OF
THE DENTAL HYGIENE FOR
CALIFORNIA. THE BOARD IS ONE OF
MANY PROFESSIONAL LICENSING
BOARDS UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
WE WERE CREATED IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE AT THE COMMITTEE AND
SUBSEQUENTLY BECAME A BOARD. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. CURRENTLY MORE
THE ONLY A PART OF THE DENTAL
HYGIENE BYKEEPING BOARD IN THE
NATION. WITH THE OVERSIGHT OF
ALL DENTAL HYGIENISTS. AND
DENTAL HYGIENE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE. IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
WE CONTINUALLY REVIEW AND
ANALYZE THE LAWS AND PROPOSED
NEW LEGISLATION OR AMEND
EXISTING LEGISLATION FOR
IMPROVEMENT UPDATE AND CLARITY
TO COMPLETE THE BOARD MISSION.
THE PROPOSED STATUTORY LANGUAGE
CONTAINED IN SENATE BILL BY
PRIESTS FOR EXAMINATION OF WORK
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS THE
ADDRESS FORTY ISSUES THAT HAVE
ARISEN. THESE RANGE FROM
ADDITIONAL BOARD MEMBER TERM
STAGGERING. ARMS FOR BEATING
THE OVERSIGHT OF MOBILE DENTAL
HYGIENE CLINIC TO ENHANCE
ACCESS CHECKER FOR POPULATION
IN THE PACIFIC LIFE ON
PROBATION WITH FOR ME TO LET.
IF WARRANTED THE PROVISION FOR
A HANDFUL BOARD BILITY TO
CONDUCT BUSINESS AND PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT FOR THE DENTAL
HYGIENE PROFESSION AND
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMER PROTECTION
HI I'D LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
JONES AND THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION. FOR
SPONSORING AND CO SPONSORING
THIS LEGISLATION SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR APPROVAL
OF SB FIVE THREE FOUR I'M
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY HAVE.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR. GOOD MORNING JEREMY
JENNIFER CAN I HELP WITH THE
ARMORY AT THE YEAR FOR THE-
DENTAL GENESIS AT THE- WORKING
THE DENTAL BORDICK. WE ARE
PLEASED TO HAVE AGREED ON THE
LARGELY TECHNICAL AND CLEAN UP
CHANGES IN SB FIVE THIRTY FOUR
THAT IMPROVE THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS TO BENEFIT LICENSEE
AND CLARIFY THE BOARD MAJORITY
TO OVERSEE MOBILE CLINICS.
WHICH SUPPORT THE BOARD'S
CONSUMER PROTECTION EFFORTS WE
ASK FOR YOR I. BOATS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I
HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF SENATE BILL FIVE
THREE FOUR. SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO. WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE URBIS IN SUPPORT
MISTER MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU WHAT'S NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S BEGIN WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL FIVE
THREE FOUR. SEEING NONE LET'S
ONCE AGAIN MOVED TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION VIA TELECONFERENCE
THIS. IS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY WE WILL
PROCEED. INTERMENT YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
PRESS ONE AND. ZERO TO CHAIRED
NO ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK PERFECT LET'S NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. I SEE
SENATOR PAN CENTER VALUE OF THE
FLOOR THANKS TO CHAIR AND-
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE VARIOUS
REFORMS THAT ARE IN THIS BILL I
GUESS THE- QUESTION I JUST HAD
IS- AND ANALYSIS STATE.
MENTIONED ABOUT THE BOARD TERMS
AND- SINCE GENERALLY THE BOARD
IS COMPOSED OF APPOINTEES BY
THE GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSION THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN TERMS OF HOW TO
HANDLE THIS- THE STAGGERING OF
THE TERMS TO CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY WANNA TRADE
THE BOARD WHY TRY TO DRESS THIS
ISSUE IN TERMS OF TURNOVER ON
THE BOARD. BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT- THERE ARE SOME ISSUES ARE
RAISED ABOUT- JUST EXTENDING
TERMS- IN CODE- WITHOUT
REAPPOINTMENT BY THE GOVERNOR
OTHER PROCESSES WE NORMALLY
HAVE IN PLACE AND IN TERMS OF
ENSURE ACCOUNTABILITY OF SOME
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD. SO-
SENATE JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND SURE SO OF COURSE
ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THE BILL'S
IN THE WORKS AS WE MOVE FORWARD
FROM THIS COMMITTEE INTO THE
PROCESS WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE- ADMINISTRATION AS WE
WOULD. YOU KNOW CERTAINLY WANT
TO GET HIS- SIGNATURE ON. OKAY
I APPRECIATE AS WONDERING
WHETHER THERE WAS A SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE AT LEAST RIGHT NOW.
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE JUST
STARTING THERE IS NO UPDATE ON
THATOKAY CORRECT- SO LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING. AN UPDATE
ON HOW THOSE CONVERSATIONS GO
BUT CERTAINLY- APPRECIATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF- MOVING FORWARD
THE OTHER COMPONENTS OF THE
BILL AND WOULD. BE HAPPY TO
MOVE TO BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU CENTER PANZER JONES
WITH ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES. SINGLE
MICROPHONES UP SOONER JONES OF
FORGERS TO CLOSE HIS CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I KINDLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK SAID
WE HAVE A MOTION ON SENATE BILL
FIVE THREE FOUR. I COULDN'T
HEAR OF THE BILL OKAY CENTER
ARCHULETA HAS MOVED THE BILL NO
ACTUALLY CENTER PAN DID BUT
THAT'S OKAY YOU CAN FIGHT IT
OUT LATER THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM SIX SENATE
BILL FIVE THREE FOR DEEP
PASSING RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RAW. HI ROTH AYE MELINDA'S AYE.
MELENDEZ AYE ARCHULETA AYE
ARCHULETA AYE BEATS BECKER.
DODD I THOUGHT I EGGMAN HI
EGGMAN AYE HER TADO JONES I.
JONES I LEYVA LEAVE A AYE MIN
AYE MAN AYE NEWMAN HI NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHOI BOGUE I'M A
TERRIBLE GUY OPINION HI CAN I
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
SUFFICIENT TO MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
CEREMONY YOU ARE PRESENTING
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
TODAY ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PROCEED.
HELLO. HELLO. HELLO.
OKAY. THURMOND IS WE ARE TRYING
TO GET CENTER LIMON SHE IS.
SORRY FEDERAL MOTOR YOU READY
TO PROCEED I AM L. PERFECT
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAD
SENATORS I WOULD LIKE TO START
TODAY BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR SOLAR CAN
CUSTOMERS ROOFTOP SOLAR IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS WE ALSO WANT TO
ENSURE THAT BAD ACTORS ARE NOT
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE SYSTEM
THEY HAVE BEEN BAD ACTORS THAT
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF SENIOR
SPANISH SPEAKERS AND LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL WILL
HOLD SOLAR CONTRACTS TO THE
SAME STANDARD AS THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACTS ALTHOUGH
SOLAR IS OFTEN CONSIDERED A
HOME IMPROVEMENT THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THAT SOLAR CONSUMERS
HAVE CONTRACT CANCELLATION
RIGHT DOWN PAYMENT SECURITY AND
NOT REQUIRED TO PAY FULL INTO
THE WORK IS COMPLETED. THIS
BILL WILL ALSO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE CONSUMER.
EVEN STILL. INDIVIDUALS CAN
WORK FOR MANY CONTRACTORS. THIS
BILL REQUIRE THE SALES PERSON
TO DISCLOSE THE CONTRACTORS
THEY ARE WORKING WITH THAT THE
CONSUMER CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION. I HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THE LOTUS WENT BACK AND LOU
THIS ONLY ABOUT FROM THE LOTUS
WHAT THE FOUNDATION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR YOUR WITNESSES MAY
PROCEED PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
OUR TIME LIMITATIONS. IS WHAT
THE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR MONOLITHIC COMMITTEE
PARTICULAR SPELL IS YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE BEEN MANY MANY
COMPLAINTS BUT PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN NO SOLUTION SO IT
RESET THAT BUTTON FIVE IS THE
WAY THAT WE CAN FINALLY HAVE
COMPLETION FOR THIS PROBLEM. IT
WASN'T A- SOME OF OUR PEOPLE
BOB IN YOU TO MY- SO. THAT IN
PUT IN THE CODE OF CONDUCT
OPPOSERS OF THE- WITH THAT
DEFINITELY. I WOULD LIKE IT'S A
DRUG TO LITERALLY. OUR ORDINARY
AND HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THIS.
BUT IT'S A PROBLEM WITH MANY
YEARS. THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT.
SIGNIFICANT EVENTS THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR HARD WORK THAT IT
TO BY THE BROUGHT BY THE POUND
AND REPRESENTATIVE SEVEN
COMMUNITY FOR HOMEOWNER WHO
HAVE LIMITED ACCESS TO LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER OR BUSINESS LAWYER
ASKING FOR YOU TO HELP PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE HOMEOWNERS
WHO ARE APPROACH BY THE SOLAR
INDUSTRY TO HAVE SOME
ASSURANCES TO HELP THEM PROTECT-THEIR HOME FROM ABUSE OF PACE
ASSESSMENTS UNDER REGULATORS
SOLAR INDUSTRY SELF. THANKS
CONTRACTORS THE BILL WOULD GIVE
SOMETHING CREATE SOME SAFETY
GUARD FOR HOMEOWNERS SOME OF
THOSE HOLDING OWNING A HOME IS
NOT JUST AN AMERICAN DREAM COME
TRUE BUT THE ONLY ASK THAT OUR
FAMILY WILL EVER HAVE TO GET
THOSE ROOTS COMMUNITY AND THE
LEGACY WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL ITSELF BUT THE SEVEN FIFTY
OF OUR HOMEOWNERS IN OUR
CONSUMERS PROTECTIONS THAT
MATTER ON THE BACK OF ISSUES
WITH SOLDIERS. AND ALSO WITH
HOME IMPROVEMENT HOMEOWNERS
LIKE LOCAL MEDIA ELAINE IS THAT
PART HERE WOULD HAVE KNOWN THE
TRUTH- CERTIFYING THAT THEIR
HOME AND THAT IT WAS THEIR NAME
ON THEIR HOME WITHIN THAT I
BELIEVE A WEEK LATER WITH SOLAR
PANELS THAT DIDN'T WORK AND
MESSED UP THEIR AC AND ALSO PUT
IN A SECOND UNDER. THEY
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE NEVER
CONCRETE THEY WERE JUST TRYING
TO DO THE RIGHT THING AND HERE
AND LISTEN TO HOW THEY COULD
BREAK A LONDONER BIG BILL AND
LOCAL HOW THEY COULD BE PART OF
BEING GOING GREEN OUR COMMUNITY
NEEDS YOUR HELP THIS BILL WILL
HELP US GET SOME SAFEGUARDS
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE
WORKED IN THE PAST THREE YEARS
WITH MORE BY MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED PLUS MAN HOURS AND THE
TASK FORCE WITH THE STATE.
COMMUNITY AND COUNTY AND OTHER
INDUSTRIES TO HELP US COME WITH
THE SOLUTION THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF A SOLUTION FOR OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE ARE ASKING FOR
A YES VOTE AND. SEVEN SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO BOTH
YOU FOR PART. TODAY WILL NOW
HEAR FROM. A SUPPORT IN THE
GALA I SEE NO. WITNESSES A THE
GALLERY ARE THERE WITH THIS IN
ROOM TWELVE WHICH TO. IN SOME.
OF THE BILL I NO WAY. LET'S
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO. VIA THE TO. OF US IN
SUPPORT MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU LET'S NOT FALL THE
SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL SEVEN. FIFTY SEVEN I SEE
NO WITNESSES. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF THIS MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD. PLEASE
PROMPT ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY WE WILL
PROCEED. FOR THOSE OF YOU
WISHING TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO PRESS
ONE. ZERO MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. PERFECT LET'S NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MY
COLLEAGUES- HERE IN THE CHAMBER
AND- PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I
SEE SENATOR PAN WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK CENTER PRINTER OF THE
FLOOR THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER JUST A QUICK QUESTION ON
THE I BELIEVE THERE IS AN
AMENDMENT TO. THE LEAD THE
SURCHARGE WAS THURMOND AND
TAKEN. YES OKAY THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OR
COMMENTS. BURKE CONCERNS
SITTING NO MICROPHONES UP.
CENTER LIMóN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU TEARS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIVE SEVEN
CENTER DONE MOVES THE BILL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIVE SEVEN. DO YOU
PASSED AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED WE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
AND COMMUNICATIONS HI. I ROTH
HI I AND II MELINDA'S AYE
ARCHULETA PURGE OUT IBEATS.
BAKER DODD I DODD AYE EGGMAN
AYE EGGMAN AYE HER TADO JONES
JONES I LEYVA HI LEAVE AYE MIN
OUR MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU ABODE HI BUT CHAO
ABODE APN HI. CAN I. THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. IT SYMBOL IN THE
SENATE BILL. ONE TWO ZERO TWO.
I'M IN THE BACK OF HIS CHAIR
THINKER YOU MAY PROCEED THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN MY REMARKS BY THINKING
THAT SHARING COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF ON
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD ENSURE WE
ARE PROTECTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS I ALSO WANT TO COMMIT TO
TAKING THE AGREED UPON
AMENDMENTS INTO THE BILL BEFORE
IT IS HEARD IN THE GEO
COMMITTEE IF THE BILL PASSES
TODAY. SENATE BILL ONE O. TWO
SIX TO PROVIDE SOME COMMONSENSE
PROTECTIONS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES A YEAR AGO
CALIFORNIA WAS UNDER IMMENSE
PRESSURE TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
KEVIN AND TO CURB THE PRIMARY
VECTORS OF TRANSMISSION IN THIS
EFFORT THE GOVERNOR DECLARED A
STATE OF EMERGENCY AND ISSUED
THE FIRST IN THE NATION
STATEWIDE STATE HOME ORDER THAT
FORCED BUSINESSES TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS. RESTAURANTS BARS
AND HAIR SALONS ROLE REQUIRED
TO SHUT DOWN MANY OF THEM
PERMANENTLY AT THE BEGINNING
MANY OF US ACCEPTED THE
SOBERING FACT THAT CLOSURES
WERE NECESSARY TO TRY AND
MITIGATE THE TRANSMISSION OF
THIS VIRUS AS A WEEKS A MONTH
PASSED BY IT BECAME CLEAR THAT
SHUT DOWN ORDERS WERE HAVING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT A NEGATIVE
EFFECT ON THESE INDUSTRIES. THE
NATIONAL RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION
IN THIS STUDY FROM SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUND THAT DURING
THE FIRST SIX MONTHS OF THE
SHUTDOWN ORDERS NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESTAURANTS
PERMANENTLY. OR TEMPORARILY
CLOSED THEIR DOORS LEAVING
THREE MILLION WORKERS WITHOUT
JOBS. IN CALIFORNIA ALONE YEP
STUDY INDICATED THAT MORE THAN
NINETEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES WILL HAVE
PERMANENTLY SHUT THEIR DOORS
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
STILL HOVERING AROUND 9% IN THE
CONTINUED LIMITATION TO
RESTAURANTS AND BARS I BELIEVE
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE TIME TO CUT
THEM SOME REGULATORY SLACK. S.
B. WANTED TO AS AMENDED WILL
NARROWLY TAILOR. EXCUSE ME IS A
NARROWLY TAILORED MEASURES
SEEKING TO PROHIBIT THE
REVOCATION SUSPENSION OR
ISSUANCES OF FINES AND
PENALTIES FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
DEMONSTRATED THEY COMPLIED
SUBSTANTIALLY WITH ORDERS AND
CITATIONS DURING THE STATE
SHUTDOWN ORDERS. THE CHANGING
NATURE OF EMERGENCY ORDERS FROM
MONTH TO MONTH CREATED
HARDSHIPS FOR MANY OF THESE
BUSINESSES SEEKING TO COMPLY.
FROM BEING FORCED TO LIMIT
CAPACITY 25% TO PURCHASING
TENTS AND HEATERS AND PICNIC
TABLES AND OTHER OUTDOOR
COVERINGS FOR OUTDOOR DINING
THESE BUSINESSES HAVE TRIED TO
PLAY BY THE RULES BUT SOME
STILL FOUND THEMSELVES IN
VIOLATIONS OF ONE THING OR
ANOTHER. CHANGING THE RULES OF
THE GAME WHILE THE GAME IS
BEING PLAYED I IS NOT HOW WE
SHOULD BE TREATING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THE RESTAURANT
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY OFTEN
OPERATE ON SHOESTRING MARGINS
WERE ANY LIMITATION ON DINING
CAPACITY INDOORS OR OUT CAN BE
CATASTROPHIC FINANCIALLY. IF
THE SMALL BUSINESSES FACE
LENGTHY SUSPENSIONS OR
REVOCATIONS FOR MINOR AND
CURABLE INFRACTIONS AS A STATE
BEGINS TO REOPEN. IT WILL ONLY
ADD TO THEIR FINANCIAL PAIN. I
DO APPLIED SEVENTY EFFORTS WE
JUST AS A LEGISLATURE TAKEN TO
ASSIST SMALL BUSINESSES THIS
YEAR ALREADY SUCH AS WAIVING
LICENSE FEE RENEWALS AND
PROVIDING GRANTS SOME OF THOSE
BILLS WE HAVE VOTED ON JUST
THIS MORNING IN THIS COMMITTEE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT ASSISTANCE
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF. HARDSHIP
RESTAURANT SOMEONE IN BURNERS
TO REAP HAVE INSURED BY
DEPUTIZED OFFICIALS SEEKING OUT
VIOLATIONS. IN A MOMENT YOU
WILL HEAR FROM TWO WITNESSES
WHO CAN DESCRIBE TO YOU THE
HARSH REALITY OF WHAT BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE FACING. I HOPE YOU
WILL UNDERSTAND THEIR PLIGHT
AND FURTHER RECOGNIZE THE
REASON WHY WE ARE PLANNING TO
AMENDED THIS MEASURE FURTHER TO
PROTECT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO ARE BEING DEVASTATED. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE VERY SIMPLE THEY
PROHIBIT THE INITIATION OF
FORMAL DISCIPLINE ENFORCEMENT
ACTION WHICH MAY INCLUDE A FINE
IMPOSING A PENALTY OR LICENSE
REVOCATION. FOR LICENSEE'S
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH ANY
KEVIN NINETEEN STATE OF
EMERGENCY ORDER IF THE LICENSEE
DEMONSTRATES THEY HAVE TAKEN
CORRECTIVE ACTION TO RESPOND TO
THESE NOTICES. I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE DANA TANNER THE OWNER
SQUIRES A BAR IN THE HARBOR IN
RESTAURANT CALLED RESTORATION
LONG BEACH FOLLOWED BY MR MARC
BERGER'S PRESIDENT OF THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONSULTING
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN THANK YU
SENATOR YOUR WITNESSES MAY
PROCEED PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
OUR TIME CONSTRAINTS. PLEASE
PROCEED. MISTER BREWER DANA
TAYLOR OKAY PLEASE PROCEED HI
MY NAME IS DAN YEAH. MANY DATA
CENTER I AM THE OWNER OF
RESTORATION IN LONG BEACH FOR
SEVEN YEARS AS WELL FIRED BAR
IN LA HABRA CALIFORNIA- AND SO
I HAD A BUSINESS IN L. A.
COUNTY AS WELL AS A BUSINESS.
IN ORANGE COUNTY AND- THANK
FOUND IT RIGHT THEY CAN TELL
YOU WHAT HAPPENS WITH ME THANK
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
MYSELF AND MY RESTAURANT HAVE
BEEN RECEIVING HARSH. PENALTIES
FROM THE CITY OF LONG BEACH.
NINE OF. THEM LEADING FEELS
LIKE YOU PROP. MAKING EXAMPLE
OF ME IN. I CHOSE TO. I'M GONNA
GET EMOTIONAL I TO SUPPORT
MIGHT BE TO MEMBERS ALL OF THE
THINGS. BUT PROVIDE OUTDOOR
DINING AND OUT WHETHER PEOPLE
WITH ME BE A TAKEN TO PROVIDE
THOSE JOB. AND HERE- I RECEIVED
PLUS YOU SO FOR UP OUT TO THE
MOST MOCK. FIVE TWENTY MISTER.
I'VE HAD NO. WITH BAIL AT A
HIGH THOUSAND DOLLARS. TRYING
TO PROVE JOBS AND COOK FOOD.
WHAT CITY PROP. THOUGHT PRESS
CONFERENCE PROBABLY DID NOT.
LENDER MIGHT. ONE DAY BEFORE
THE STATE WATER CODE OPEN UP
RESULT MY HOPES INTERVIEW
TOGETHER BACK TO ME. EVEN
THOUGH I'M IN COMPLIANCE
CURRENTLY- MARCH MY BEST LIKE
THE WAS GREAT AND PARTNERS IN
THE TO APPEAL IT IF I EVEN WANT
TO TRY SAY OKAY. MY GOD METER
WITH THE FOR ME ONE DAY THE OF
FACT AND THEY WERE TO LET ME
HAVE A LETTER. WAS MY LANDLORD
INFECTED THE IN SIXTEEN AND I
BEING BY CITY. HI PARKLET DIE
WITH TO GET WEEK AFTER THE
STATE OPEN BACK UP. IF YOU
THINK DONE IT WILL WORK ORDER
IF YOU CAME IN AND TRIED
QUICKLY WANTED FOR ME BUT I
REFUSE TO CALL. I FELT LIKE AT
THE POINT YOU THOUGH IT MAY IT
SO SENSE FOR ME TO TRY TO THE
THEM EVEN THOUGH I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO WORK WITH. BUT I'VE
NOTICED BUT CLOSE AT THE POINT-
MEDICARE MEMBERS WANT WE I DO
NOT KNOW I LOOKED PHONE CALL
AND THE NO REASON. ALL THE
WHILE THREE MILES PEOPLE ARE
GETTING IN AND OUTSIDE.
INTERESTS AND THEN IN THE
HOPPER AND I'VE ONLY HAD THE
CONTACT ME. ONE AND I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE MY- WHICH WOULD
HELP PROVIDE. MONEY FOR MY
MOTHER TO KEEP HER GOING TO.
HAVE I'M JUST ASKING FOR. I'M
ASKING FOR YOU. I'M ASKING TO
SPLIT. FOR THESE BUSINESSES.
BECAUSE SMALL BUSINESS CAN'T
SURVIVE THROUGH THE YEAR. WE
NOT. BEING ON. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BREWER NEXT. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THE TO IN SOME OF A . Y. OH
TWO. IN MY PRACTICE AN
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE LICENSE
CONSULTANT I REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF LICENSEES AND
LICENSED PREMISES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. I ALSO OWN
MULTIPLE LICENSE BUSINESSES
INCLUDING SEVERAL BARS BOTH IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY. I HAVE BEEN CONSULTED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC I'VE BEEN CONSULTED
MANY TIMES UP ON HOW TO COMPLY
WITH THE MANY ORDERS THAT WERE.
BUT PUBLISHED DURING THE
OUTBREAK. THE COBIT ENDEMIC IS
PUT BAR AND RESTAURANT OWNERS
IN THE IN BETWEEN TWO EQUAL
EQUAL BUT DIFFICULT CHOICES ALL
OF THE IN EVER CHANGING HEALTH
HOURS WHICH MEANT LAYING OFF
EMPLOYEES CLOSING YOUR BUSINESS
LOSING YOUR LIKE LIVELIHOOD OR
BREAKING IN THE ORDERS AND ALSO
AND FACING TOUGH PENALTIES AND
FINES AND- POTENTIALLY
ENDANGERING PUBLIC HEALTH. I
COMMEND THE ABC FOR ALL OF THE
FLEXIBILITY AND THEIR APPROACH
TO ENFORCEMENT HOWEVER I
BELIEVE THAT THE AGENCY WAS
TASKED WITH ENFORCING ORDERS
THAT WERE NOT WITH IN THE
PRIMARY MISSION OF ENFORCING
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE LAW. UNLIKE
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT
REGULATED BY SPECIFIC AGENCY
THE ABC WITH LEVERAGE TO CREATE
FEAR AMONG RESTAURANT OWNER AND
BAR OWNERS IN AN EFFORT TO
FORCE COMPLIANCE EVEN THOUGH
THEIR ORDERS WERE NOT DIRECTLY
RELATED TO OUR COLLECTIVE RICH
SERVICE. I BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL WILL BE REVIEWED LEAD YOU
WILL LEAD THE ABC OF THE BURDEN
OF TRYING TO BALANCE ITS DUTY
OF ENFORCING THE LAWS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND ITS
COMPASSION FOR THE SMALL
BUSINESS OPERATORS THAT WERE
FORCED TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TWO
EVILS. I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL WOULD GIVE BUSINESS OWNERS
WHO DID THE BEST THEY COULD
UNDER VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES PEACE OF MIND
THAT IF THEY WERE AND FORTUNATE
TO SURVIVE THAT THEY WOULD DO
NOT. HAVE ANY MORE EXPOSURE TO
FINES AND PENALTIES I ASK THAT
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND MOVING ON. TO VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU SIR WILL NOW
HEAR FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ROOM
ONE TWELVE. WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ONE OH TWO SEEING NONE LET'S
MOVE TO THE TELECONFERENCING
SERVICE FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ILL MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WAITING TO TESTIFY WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THIS PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. HERE WE DO HAVE A
PARTICIPANT THAT HAVE SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT PLACE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE SIXTY. PLEASE PROCEED. ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MOVE ON THE LINE FORTY LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE
THANK YOU FOR TAKING OUT WITH
THE BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE IN FAVOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE
SIXTY TWO. HI THIS IS TONY
ROMA'S ALLISON CAPITOL RESOURCE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. WELL NOW GO TO
LINE SIXTY AGAIN. THE COMPANY
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION COURT
WITH THE OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT
SWITCHES LEARN THE BILL. YOUR A
FIFTY THE ONLY FACTOR. IF YOU
CAN FIND YUP. LOCAL. SB WITHIN
AREA WELL I ASSUME YOU'VE
CAUGHT NECK PLEASE. PLEASE
SPEAK OUT CHAIRED ONE ELSE.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE ELSE SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU LET'S NOT FOR THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR ANY
OPPOSITION- MICHELLE GIVENS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IS
OUR FIRST WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
ON OUR CALL. MS GIVENS. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS
MACHEL GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
CALLING IN IN OPPOSITION SB ONE
OH TWO EIGHT LOCAL HEALTH
BORDERS ARE CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
DISEASE ESPECIALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC MICHAEL THAT NINETEEN
UNFORTUNATELY THE ORDER OF
SUPPORT GREATER COMPLIANCE AND
BEGIN WITH EDUCATION ONLY
ESCALATING THE FINES AND
PENALTIES ENCLOSURES AFTER
REPEATED INCIDENCES OF NON
COMPLIANCE. NOW COMPLIANT COME
IN MANY FORMS FROM OUR RIGHT
DISREGARDING THE HEALTH BORDERS
I Q. EXCEEDING CAPACITY LIMITS
NEGLECTING MATH REQUIREMENTS OR
FAILURE TO REPORT CASES AMONG
OTHER REQUIRING AGENCIES TO
PROVE A DIRECT CORRELATION FOR
EVERY INSTANCE OPEN ARIA OF
NONCOMPLIANCE AND TRANSMISSION
IS NOT FEASIBLE AND REFERS
FURTHER SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
EVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
PANDEMIC LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS RELIED ON
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT IN THE
SEATS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL WITH
A KEY PARTNER IN THIS EFFORT I
THINK ONE OF YOU WOULD PROHIBIT
EIGHTY FEET HOWEVER TRYING
PENALTY THEIR CLOSURES FOR EVEN
THE MOST EGREGIOUS CASES OF NON
COMPLIANCE. BECAUSE A DIRECT
CORRELATION FOR TRANSMISSION
LEVINE AT WOULD HAVE TO BE
ESTABLISHED FOR DURING AN
EMERGENCY COULD ACTUALLY SAVE
LIVES AND MUST NOT BE HINDERED
AND IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT.
WE MUST REGRETFULLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. REMEMBER
THERE BEEN A MAN THAT HAVE BEEN
X. TO THIS BILL THAT DEVIATE
SOME FROM THE COMMENTS NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE SO WE NEED TO GO
TO THE TELEPHONE CONFERENCE
SERVICE APOLOGIZE PLEASE PROMPT
THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING MISTER
MODERATOR. THOSE WISHING TO
SPEAK AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS
ONE BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE LINE
THAT SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK JUST A MOMENT THANK YOU.
UHHUH. WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
LINE. THIRTY FOUR. SHARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY- THIS IS MIKE
SKIP ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL
JUSTICE AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE. SURE
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THAT
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK THANK YOU LET'S TURN THE
MATTER BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER AND- THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY IF ANY.
COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. SENATOR DODD. YOU'RE
THE HIGHEST MIKE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THANK- THE CHAIR TO HIM IN THE
BILL'S AUTHOR FOR. YOUR WORKING
ON SOME AMENDMENTS- BUT THAT'S
AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE GEO I
REALLY DID WANT TO RISK BE KEPT
BRIEFLY TO THE PORTION OF THE
BILL RELATED APARTMENT AT ABC.
IT PROVIDES SOME CONTEXT. FIRST
OF ALL ABC DOES NOT HAVE
FIGHTING OF FORTY. THIS MEANS
IT'S ABC CAN'T SIMPLY SHOW UP
AND FIND A LICENSEE EVEN IF
THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING CODE
PROTOCOLS. IT IS TRUE THAT THEY
CAN SUSPEND A LICENSE. BUT THIS
ONLY OCCURS AFTER AMPLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE GIVEN. THE
BEGIN BEEN GIVEN TO THE
LICENSEE TO COMPLY. THE LAST
I'D HEARD ABC IT CONDUCTED
ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND INSPECTIONS. THOSE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
INSPECTIONS RESULTED IN SOME
KIND OF ACTION BY ABC IN ABOUT
TWO TO THREE HUNDRED CASES.
THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY ONE
PERCENT. THIS MEANS THAT NINETY
NINE POINT 9% OF LICENSEES WERE
EITHER FOUND TO BE COMPLIED OR
AFTER BEING MADE AWARE OF THEIR
NON COMPLIANCE. MADE THE
CHANGES NECESSARY. TO COMPLY.
SO WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THOSE
POINT 1% OF CASES UNDER CURRENT
LAW ABC IS ONLY ALLOWED TO
PURSUE A SUSPENSION. STOOP OF
BAY A LAWFUL ORDER THAT MEANS.
ABC CANNOT SIMPLY SHOW UP TO A
LICENSED PREMISES AND SUSPENDED
LICENSE EVEN IF THEY ARE
CLEARY VIOLATING THE CURRENT
HEALTH ORDER THAT'S OF COURSE
OF PROCESS. IF A LICENSEE
OBSERVED TO BE IN VIOLATION.
THE DEPARTMENT NOTIFIES A
LICENSEE AND PROVIDES THEM WITH
IF OPPORTUNITY COMPLY IF THEY
COMPLY THAT TO WORK AGAINST IF
THEY DON'T COMPLY ABC. I CAN
THEN TAKE ACTION THIS USUALLY
MEANS LICENCES PLACED ON THE
FIFTEEN DAY PROBATIONARY PERIOD
DURING THIS PERIOD THE LICENSEE
IS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
ALCOHOL AS LONG AS THEY COMPLY
IF THEY DON'T THEY COULD FACE A
FIFTEEN DAY SUSPENSION. IF IT
REACHES THIS STAGE A LICENSEE
COMPARE FIVE INSTEAD OF SERVING
THAT SUSPENSION IF THEY CHOOSE
TO SERVE THE SUSPENSION THEY
CAN STILL CONTINUE TO SERVE
FOOD OR NON ALCOHOLIC DRINKS.
IF THE LICENSEE STILL FAILS TO
COMPLY ABC COULD DO IT EVEN
LONGER SUSPENSION OR EVEN
REMOVE REMOVED TO REVOKE THE
LICENSE BUT AGAIN THIS WILL
ONLY OCCUR IF THE LICENSEE
WILLFULLY REFUSES TO FOLLOW THE
HEALTH ORDER. I'D MENTION ALL
THIS TO EMPHASIZE THAT THERE ISNO SUCH THING AS ABC SUSPENDING
A LICENSE TO IS COMPLIANT THEIR
LICENSES ONLY SUSPENDED AFTER
THE LICENSEE HAS WILLFULLY TIME
AND AGAIN REFUSED TO FOLLOW
COBIT HELPED ORDERS. I
UNDERSTAND IN IN THE SUPPORTER
OF MALL BUSINESS I SPOKEN
NUMEROUS TIMES ON THIS FLOOR-
IN ORDER TO HELP SMALL BUSINESS.
A OF THE I UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHAT THIS IS THE TO OUR- IN THE
PORTS A CAT ALPHA LIGHTS. BUT I
DON'T WITH MEMBERS THE SENATE A
NUMBER OF BILLS THE SEEK TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL HELP TO
THESE BUSINESSES. HOWEVER I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO REALLY
CONSIDER THE NINETY NINE POINT
9% OF THE LICENSEES WHO ARE
DOING THEIR PART IN COMPLYING
WITH THE HEALTH ORDER
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
AGREE WITH IT OR NOT. I THINK
THIS BILL IS UNFAIR TO THEM AND
PLACES THEM AT A HUGE
DISADVANTAGE AND I CANNOT
SUPPORT THAT. I KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE AYE WE DOES ABOUT
THESE EVENTS BUT IS THE CHAIR
OF GEO I THINK THE CURRENT LAW
ALREADY PROVIDES FOR MORE THAN
ENOUGH OPPORTUNITY. FOR
LICENSES- LICENSEES TO COMPLY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU- CENTER PAM. THANK YOU A
THIS CHAIR- I TO. PLUS STAFF
SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL EVEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
AND- I HOPE I DON'T HAVE TO
REMIND THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE DATA. WE HAVE
EVENTUALLY HAD ALMOST SIXTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS DIED OF
THIS DISEASE. THIS IS A
CONTAGIOUS DISEASE IT SPREADS
IT SPREADS QUICKLY IF NOT
LIMITED. AND IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT THOSE PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
ARE NECESSARY TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF THIS DISEASE THAT NOT
ONLY IS COURSE KILLED SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS BUT ALSO IS ALSO
HOSPITALIZED OR INJURED MANY
OTHERS. AND FRANKLY- BUSINESS
WILL BE DOWN IN RESTAURANTS.
WHEN THE DIZZY WHEN THE VIRUS
SPREADS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
AFRAID TO GO OUTSIDE RIGHTFULLY.
AND I THINK IF WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT'S HAPPENING TO-
BUSINESSES WE SHOULD BE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO STOP THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL- WOULD
ALLOW THAT ONE POINT 1% AND
I'VE YOU KNOW FRACTION OF A
PERCENT- BASICALLY MORE TIME.
TO EVENTUALLY SPREAD THE VIRUS
EVEN FURTHER- BY CAN TRYING TO
CONTINUE OPERATIONS WHEN
CLEARLY THERE'S BEEN AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO- MAKE
CORRECTIONS OR TO ADD TO MEET
THE- PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS. SO
WITH THAT YOU KNOW OUR FIRST
ROLES GOVERNMENT'S PUBLIC
SAFETY AND YOUR DOES THIS DATA
VIRUSES YOU ARE FROM A BULLET
TO OUR FROM A FIRE. AND I THINK
WE NEED TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THOUGHT THAT I CERTAINLY AM
GOING TO BE OPPOSING THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THERE BATES. OKAY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN I DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING
THESE AMENDMENTS I THINK IT
GETS US WHERE WE NEED TO BE
WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
PANDEMIC BECAUSE CERTAINLY HAS
DONE TO RESTAURANTS IN
PARTICULAR BUT I DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR- THE
AMENDMENTS DO REMOVE THE PIECE
ABOUT HAVING TO PROVE A
TRANSMISSION OCCURRED ARE
BECAUSE A LACK OF IT OF
COMPLIANCE SO MY QUESTION IS.
ARE YOU TOOK THE AMOUNT OF SO
I'M ASSUMING YOU THINK THE BILL
WILL STILL BE EFFECTIVE IN
PROTECTING OUR BUSINESSES COULD
YOU- KIND ELABORATE ON THAT
SENATOR MELENDEZ. SURE SURE
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES- SO WE
DID NARROW THE BILL THAT WAS
AND- IS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
IT WAS. AN ENDEAVOR THAT WE
EMBARKED UPON WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL IS TAILORED IN A WAY THAT
MADE SENSE THAT WASN'T. GIVING
BUSINESSES THE ABILITY TO JUST
SAY WELL I'M NOT GOING TO
FOLLOW THE RULES THAT'S THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE BILL DOES IT GIVES
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY. TO CURE
ANY MISTAKES TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE IN COMPLIANCE WE HAVE
HAD SITUATIONS WHERE A
RESTAURANT YOU KNOW DINING
OUTDOORS HAS BEEN CITED
BECAUSE- THEIR TABLES WERE.
ACCORDING TO THE PERSON WHO
SHOWED UP FROM THE STATE
THERE'S THEIR TABLE WAS HALF
INSIDE HALF OUTSIDE THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BE FINING
PEOPLE FOR. FAMILY RECOGNIZED-
THAT THE SENATE SENATOR DODD
YOU KNOW SPOKE ABOUT WHAT ABC
CANNING CAN'T DO. WE ALSO NEED
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS CAN DO AND CANNOT DO
AND I THIS IS YOU KNOW THIS IS
A WHOLE EFFORT WHERE PEOPLE.
CAN BE FINE CAN BE CITED CAN
HAVE LICENSES. REVOKED AND IT
HAS. TERRIFIED THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY I THINK GIVEN A TIME
WHEN WE ARE PASSING BILLS THAT
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF RELIEF Y.
EITHER EITHER FINANCIAL. OR
GRANT OR EXTENDING THE LENGTH
OF TIME FOR WHICH YOU CAN COME
INTO COMPLIANCE WITH C. CHOIR
ANYTHING ELSE. WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO HELP ALL OF THESE
BUSINESSES THE ONES THAT WERE
MOST HURT. WORDT RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY WERE THIS ALLIANCE YOU
KNOW ALL THESE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES WORD WE'RE JUST
DECIMATED SO I'M NOT ASKING
THAT THE SENATE PASSED A BILL
THAT SAYS PEOPLE CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT AND- YOU
KNOW THROW THE RULES OUT THE
DOOR THAT'S NOT WHAT THE
BUILDERS WE'VE- VERY
AGGRESSIVELY TAYLOR THIS BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT ONLY APPLIES
TO PEOPLE. WHO HAVE ABSOLUTELY
BEEN DOING WHAT THEY NEED TO DO
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CODE ORDERS
AND IT ONLY. APPLIES FROM THE
TIME THAT THE EMERGENCY ORDER
STARTED UNTIL THE TIME AND IT
IS NOT IN PERPETUITY SO I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION. I
JUST A COMMENT I THINK WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF-
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THAT THE
CONTACT TRACING OUR WORK AND WE
KNOW THAT AT A CERTAIN POINT.
IN PARTICULAR WITH RESTAURANTS
WHO WERE REALLY FOLLOWING TO
THE LETTER OF THE LAW. CONTACT
TRACING WITH HELPING IN UNTIL
WE FIND A WAY TO MAKE THAT
REALLY WORK AND IT CERTAINLY
REQUIRES. A HUGE ALL LABOR
INTENSIVE EFFORT BUT IT IS
VITAL I THINK CERTAINLY TO
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT ALSO TO
HAPPEN ON THE VIABILITY. OF FOR
OUR OF FRONTLINE SERVICE-
ESTABLISHMENTS WHICH RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY CERTAINLY HAS BEEN ONE
SO I WOULD JUST ADD THAT TO THE
COMMENTARY. THAT CONTACT
TRACING HAS TO BE EFFECTIVE.
FOR OUR BUSINESSES REALLY ARE
PUNISHED WHEN THEY NEED TO BE
THANK. YOU THANK YOU CENTERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER- SO I
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF THIS IS
HE STATED- WHICH IS TRYING TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
PLAYED BY THE RULES- BUT
INADVERTENTLY FAIL TO DO SO AND
I THINK THE EXAMPLE YOU GAVE OF
OUTDOOR DINING THAT WAS
INADVERTENTLY PARTLY ENDORSES A
SYMPATHETIC ONE. I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION FOR YOU IS YOU
KNOW WHY IT DOES YOUR BILL NOT
HAVE LANGUAGE AROUND INTENT OR
NEGLIGENCE- BECAUSE THE WAY
IT'S STRUCTURED NOW. IT SEEMS
LIKE IF YOU JUST REPEATEDLY AND
WILLFULLY FLOUT THE RULES AS
LONG AS YOU KIND OF ISSUE A MEA
CULPA AT SOME POINT AND CORRECT
YOUR ACTIONS REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THOSE ARE INTENTIONAL
VIOLATIONS OR UNINTENTIONAL-
THIS BILL WOULD APPLY TO THAT
SO EIGHT I KNOW YOU TAILORED
THIS BUT BUT AS I READ THE
LANGUAGE NOW IT STATES THAT. IF
THE LICENSEE DEMONSTRATED. THAT
CORRECT TAX WAS TAKEN RESPOND
TO ANY PRIOR NOTICE. AND
THEY'RE OFF THEY GET THEY GET A
FREE PASS AND I THINK WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT I THINK
OTHERS HAVE EXPRESSED AS WELL
AS IS THE PROBLEM OF THE
WILLFUL REPEATED OFFENDER- AND
ANYONE IN BUSINESS I'VEHEARD
OF IN MY DISTRICT THAT HAS FIVE
BEEN FINE. IS A BAR THAT
REPEATEDLY REFUSED TO LISTEN TO
A LONG FORTUNATE ORTIZ- WAS
VISITED THREE TIMES BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAD BEEN CONSULTED
BY LOCAL COUNTY AND STATE
OFFICIALS AND STILL REFUSED TO
CLOSE IT WOULD HAVE WAS
ATTENTION INDOOR NIGHTCLUB WITH
NO MASKS AS ONLY AFTER. ONE OF
THE MANAGERS LAID HANDS ON A
POLICE OFFICER THAT ANY ACTIONS
TAKEN AND NOW SENATOR DODD MY
COLLEAGUES MENTION. ONLY TWO
HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED.
BUSINESSES HAVE ANY CORRECT
ACTION MAYBE SEASIDE MY
QUESTION IS. YEAH WONDER OFTEN
DOES YOUR SITUATION ACTUALLY
HAPPENED WHERE ABC- IS TAKING
AWAY SOMEONE'S LYSONS ARE
ISSUING A FINE- BECAUSETHAT'S
NOT WHAT I'M HEARING ABOUT I'M
HEARING MORE ABOUT THE REPEATED
WILLFUL- IN A VIOLATOR. AND TO
WHY NOT TRY TO TAILOR THIS
FURTHER TO JUST ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE WHO INNOCENTLY VIOLATE.
THE RULES AS OPPOSED TO THOSE
WHO WILLFULLY INTENTIONALLY AND
REPEATEDLY VIOLATE THE RULES.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION AND I BELIEVE THAT
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THE BILL
DOES EXACTLY WHAT YOU ARE
SUGGESTING. IT'S- IT IS TAKE SO
THAT YOU CAN'T IT DOESN'T APPLY
TO SOMEONE WHO IS WILFULLY.
FLOUTING THE RULES I MEAN YOU-
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE SOME
BUSINESSES WHO HAVE DONE SO
THIS DOESN'T APPLY TO THEM AND
YOU HAVE TO SHOW SOME SORT OF
PROOF. JUST SAYING WELL I TRIED
DOESN'T CUT IT THANKS THAT'S
NOT WHAT'S ALLOWABLE IN THIS
BILL BUT WE HAVE TO WORK WITH
THESE BUSINESSES WHO HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT UP. IN TRYING TO COMPLY
IN TRYING TO KEEP THEIR HEAD
ABOVE WATER AND KEEP THEIR
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYED EMPLOYED SO
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO.
LIVE YOU KNOW WITH THE FAMILY
MEMBER GOING GOVERNMENT
ASSISTANCE OR WATCH THEIR
DREAMS GO UP IN SMOKE MANY OF
WHOM YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MANY EMPLOYEES. IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHO NEED
THAT JOB. SO THE BILL IS. NOT
IT JUST IT DOESN'T DO WHAT YOU
THINK IT DOES IT IS TERRY
TAILORED. SO THAT YOU CANNOT
GIVE SOMEONE. THE GREEN LIGHT
TO FLOUT THE RULES SO THE WAY I
READ THE LANGUAGE RIGHT NOW
WITH THE AMENDMENTS IS THAT IF
I VIOLATE SO LET'S JUST TAKE IT
WHEN YOU'RE WITNESSES. SAMPLE
YOUR FIRST WITNESS I LOOKED HER
UP AND- SHE REPEATEDLY VIOLATED
THE LAW NUMEROUS VISITS FROM
LONG BEACH LAW ENFORCEMENT-
AND- THE GAS WAS ACTUALLY SHUT
OFF AN ATTEMPT TO GET HER TO
SHUT DOWN THE RESTAURANT AND
SHE CONTINUED TO. REFUSE TO
CLOSE DOWN. AT INDOOR DINING IS
WHAT THE NEW SAYS- AND FINALLY
YOU KNOW AND SHE MADE A BIG
DEAL OUT OF THIS IN THE MEDIA.
BUT UNDER YOUR LANGUAGE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IF IN RESPONSE
TO LATEST NOTICE THE PRIOR
NOTICE SHE THEN DECIDES TO
DEMONSTRATE CORRECTIVE ACTION.
SHE GETS A FREE PASS REGARDLESS
OF THE FACT THAT SHE WILLFULLY
DEFIED SEVERAL ORDERS- THAT
LEAD TO THAT POINT AND I GUESS
THAT'S MY CONCERN. WOULD YOUR
LANGUAGE COVER SOMEONE LIKE MS
TANNER. WHO REPEATEDLY SAID I'M
NOT GOING TO FOLLOW THE RULES%
BECAUSE I DON'T AGREE WITH
THEM- BY FINALLY. THE LAST ONE-
OF SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLY WITH
THE LAST NAMES LIKE I GET A-
BECAUSE TO ME THAT IF THAT'S
THE READING AND THAT'S HOW I
READ THE LANGUAGE. THAT DOES
RAISE THE CONCERNS OF MY
SENATOR ABOUT MY FOOT IN MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM NAPA REYES.
ABOUT PENALIZING BUSINESSES THE
NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE COMPLIED
THIS. PANDEMIC. AND I GUESS
THAT'S A GOOD. MISS THEM YEAH
RUSSIAN I'M A MATE MAYBE IT'S
JUST A SIGNIFICANT DISAGREEMENT
ON LANGUAGE I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS WOULD YOUR BILL ALLOW RELIEF
FOR YOUR WITNESS THAT YOU THE
TESTIFIED. SENATOR MAN I'D I
FEEL LIKE I HAVEN'T
COMMUNICATED THIS CLEARLY
ENOUGH SO I'M GOING TO READ TO
YOU- THE CHANGE IN THE
AMENDMENT WHICH SAYS. THAT ONLY
A BUSINESS WHICH HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY ATTEMPTED TO
COMPLY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
BORDERS OR HAS RECEIVED
MULTIPLE NOTICES OF CORRECTION
AND HAS WORKED TO ADDRESS. ALL
OF THESE DEFICIENCIES WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR RELIEF FROM
LICENSE REVOCATION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THAT YOU HAVE
TRIED IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO SAY I
DON'T WANT TO AND IT IS NOT
ENOUGH TO SAY. WELL I TRIED BUT
YOU YOU NOW YOU HAVE NOTHING
TO SHOW THAT YOU FOR INSTANCE.
THE RESTAURANT OWNER WHO HAD
TABLES. THAT WERE KIND OF HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW HOUSE OUT OF THE
INDOOR AND OUTDOOR DINING AREA.
OKAY SO. IT'S VERY EASY TO SAY
LOOK I MOVED THEM SO THEY'RE
COMPLETELY IN THE OUTDOOR
DINING AREA. NO HARM NO FOUL NO
PENALTY EITHER THESE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS RETIREMENT IF
THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT
THEY ARE THEY'RE WORKING TO
CORRECT I AM NOT. SUGGESTING
THAT. WE PASS A BILL THAT SAYS
NO ONE HAS TO FOLLOW ANY RULES.
AND AT ALL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
GO OUT THE WINDOW THAT'S AND
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE BILL SAYS I
HOPE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO READ
THE AMENDMENT. TO SEE THAT'S MY
INTENT. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT AND I GUESS MY READING
AMENDMENTS IS IF I GET VISITED
EIGHT TIMES AND ON THE EIGHTH
TIME I KNOW THE FIRST SEVEN BUT
ON A TIME AYE SUBSTANTIALLY
COMPLIED. I WILL BE ALLOWED
RELIEF UNDER YOUR BILL THAT'S
HOW I READ THE BILL PERHAPS
I'M- MISTAKEN- I'M GONNA BE
OPPOSING THIS RIGHT NOW JUST
BECAUSE I. DO THINK IT.
INCLUDE TOO MANY BUSINESSES
THAT- FLOUTED THE LAW AND WE
SEEN EXAMPLES OF EVERY SINGLE
PERSON I'VE READ ABOUT. THAT
HAS BEEN HAMMERED BY ABC HAS
BEEN SOMEONE WHO HAS TALKED
ABOUT HOW THESE RULES THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH THEM THEY'RE
PROBLEMATIC AND I THINK WE'RE
NOT EPIDEMIC RIGHT NOW PEOPLE
THAT DISAGREE WITH THE LAW AND
REFUSED TO FOLLOW IT. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THIS
BODY ESTABLISH AND REINFORCE
THE RULE OF LAW. THAT WE DO NOT
REWARD THOSE WHO WOULD GO OUT
AND SAY RIDE ON THE CAPITAL
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT THE
LAW DOESN'T APPLY TO THEM. AND
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
THE LAW BE APPLIED EQUALLY TO
EVERYBODY. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SEND THE MEN
CENTER JONES. IS YOUR MIKE UP
FOR A REASON. SAID JONES. YOUR
MAKE UP FOR REASON. KELLY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS. LET ME GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE BEFORE I TURN IT
BACK. TELL ME SEVEN- THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YEAH I
WAS JUST SUNDERLAND'S I KNOW
YOU TO BE A BIG SUPPORTER SMALL
BUSINESS AND I UNDERSTAND- THE
FRUSTRATION BUT LIKE MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. WELL I DON'T
KNOW ABOUT MANY MY COLLEAGUES
BECAUSE I CURRENTLY LIVE IN A
COUNTY THAT'S STILL ON THE
LOWEST TIER OF OPENING- AND
THEN YOU CAN LOOK IN THE PAPER
AND THE NEWS FOR A LOT OF MY
BUSINESS IS ALSO WHO DID NOT
COMPLY WHO WILLFULLY DID NOT
COMPLY WHO WENT ON TV ABOUT HOW
THEY WORK AND COMPLY. AND THEN
GOT VISITED BY ABC AND- THAT IT
WAS VERY WERE VERY UPSET ABOUT
THAT- AS I THINK. MANY OF US IN
HERE ALSO HEARD FROM BUSINESSES
THAT WERE COMPLAINING. OF
FEELING VERY FRUSTRATED BY
THOSE WHO ARE FLOUTING THE LAW
AND PUBLIC HEALTH BORDERS. AND
SO WELL. BY WILL YOU MAY HAVE
NARROWED THIS. DOWN I JUST I
DON'T I CANNOT SUPPORT THE
PREMISE THAT IT'S SUPPORT THAT
IT. THE IT THAT THAT IS TRYING
TO SAY THAT IF IT. HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT IF AT THE VERY END
THEN YOU SAY OKAY I'M JUST OAK
I'M SORRY- BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
THAT YOU CAN. SHOW US SOME
PLACE THAT HAD A TABLE IN AND
OUT. THAT WAS THE ONLY
VIOLATION THEY HAD THAT WAS THE
ONLY TIME THEY HAD BEEN VISITED
AND- THEY WERE COMPLIANCE WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE AND THAT THEY
WERE. FINE I JUST. DID IT. FEEL
WHICH IS THAT YOU PROVIDED DID
NOT MAKE THAT THAT POINT ALSO I
CAN'T. BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. SENATOR OF
CHILCOTE. HELLO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OR TO ASK
A QUESTION- HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
THE CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE
IMPACT THAT THEIR EXPERIENCES
BY OPERATING A BUSINESS DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND TRYING TO STAY
IN COMPLIANCE I'M SORRY COULD
YOU SAY AGAIN I APOLOGIZE TO
YOU NO WORRIES- I'VE SORT OF
SPOKEN A LITTLE FASTER COLLEGE
EYES. HAVE YOU SPOKEN TO
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING BY
OPERATING A BUSINESS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND TRYING TO STAY IN
COMPLIANCE. THANK YOU SENATOR-
I HAVE AND I WOULD IMAGINE
EVERYBODY IN HERE. HAS HEARD
FROM THESE TYPES OF BUSINESSES
AND IT HAS BEEN. A REAL
CHALLENGE IT IT'S BEEN
STRESSFUL. WE HEAR. YOU KNOW
SEEN FAMILIES BREAK UP WE HAVE
SEEN SUICIDES WE HAVE SEEN. A
NUMBER REALLY DEVASTATED
IMPACTS RELATED TO THIS
PANDEMIC IN RELATED TO PEOPLE
LOSING THEIR LIVELIHOODS IF
THEY'VE WORKED THEIR WHOLE
LIVES. TO BUILD UP SO I DON'T
THINK ANYONE IN THE CERTAINLY
START HOPE NOT IS A STRANGER TO
HEARING THOSE TYPES OF STORIES.
BUT AGAIN WITH MY BILL YOU KNOW
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS COMMITTEE
ABOUT- GIVING PEOPLE THE
IMPRESSION THAT THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WOULD LIKE. BUT
THAT SIMPLY ISN'T WHAT THE BILL
DOES AND I ON I WOULD ASK
PEOPLE. TO REMEMBER THAT IT IS.
THE RULES HAVE CHANGED A LOT.
OVER THE LAST YEAR AND SOME
LINES RELATING TO WHAT YOU CAN
AND CANNOT DO AS A BUSINESS
OWNER. AND AS A PAGER THE RULES
HAVE CHANGED A LOT- AND IT IS.
DIFFICULT TO KEEP UP WITH THE
AND TO MAINTAIN YOUR BUSINESS
ALL I'M ASKING. IS THAT WE SHOW
THE SAME AMOUNT OF DIFFERENCE
TO THESE TYPES OF BUSINESSES
AND WE AS WE HAVE TO OTHERS
WHEN WE HAVE PROVIDED FINANCIAL
RELIEF OR GRANTS OR- SOME SORT
OF RELIEF FROM HAVING TO PLAY
FOR A LICENSE. FOR ANYTHING
ELSE EVERYBODY IS JUST TRYING
TO MAKE A LIVING AND
EVERYBODY'S TRYING TO COMPLY
BEST THEY CAN'T EVEN KEEP THEIR
PATRONS SAFE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I JUST LIKE TO COME IN
AND- C. JUST LIKE TO COMMENT
THAT. I AM A VERY BUSINESS
FRIENDLY- SENATOR MY VERY MUCH
AN ADVOCATE FOR CONSUMERS AS
WELL FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
CONSUMERS AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
PERSONALLY. HAS FAMILY MEMBERS
AND FRIENDS WHO ARE UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND SO FORTH-
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
RESPECT IS BUSINESSES WHO GO
OUT OF THEIR WAY TO TRY TO MEET
THE BED AND HEALTH REQUIREMENTS
IN ORDER TO CONDUCT BUSINESSES
BUT WHAT I ALSO RESPECT IS THE
CONSUMER'S ABILITY TO CHOOSE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN THEY
WILL PATRONIZE. BUSINESSES THAT
MEET OR THEY FEEL MEET THE
HEALTH REQUIREMENTS AND
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE I HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
FRIENDS WHO WILL NOT VISIT-
PATRONIZE BUSINESSES THAT DO
NOT MEET THOSE RECORDS IT
DIDN'T THEY DON'T FEEL THAT
THEY ARE MEETING OUR THE HELP
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE THERE IN
PLACE SO I APPRECIATE THAT BY
ONE OF THE OTHER THINGS I WANT
TO MENTION IS- BOTH FROM A
FORMER SCHOOL BOARD PERSPECTIVE
AS SOMEONE WHO. UNDERSTANDS THE
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE IS THAT
MANY BUSINESSES AND PUBLIC
ENTITIES ARE AFRAID TO CONDUCT
BUSINESSES BECAUSE OF THE
LIABILITIES THAT THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE
VULNERABILITIES OF BEING THAT
SO IN GOOD FAITH- I ACTUALLY
RESPECT THE INTENT OF THE BILL
I RESPECT CONSUMERS CHOICE OF
SUPPORTING BUSINESSES- THAT.
FOLLOW OF IT SAFETY PRODUCT. I
ALSO WE- THE CONSUMERS. BUT IF
THEY DO NOT SEE THE HEALTH
WORKERS BEING THAT THEN PERHAPS
THE YOU KNOW THEY CHOOSE NOT TO
PATRONIZE THIS BUSINESS JUST
LIKE OUR FAMILY MEMBERS OR
FRIENDS DO SO. WITH THAT IN
MIND- THE GOOD INTENT OF
PROTECTING THOSE BUSINESSES ARE
ARE. TRYING TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE HEALTH.
ALSO I'M JUST ONE NOTE THAT I
DON'T NOTICE THAT THEY WE HAD A
FELLOW COLLEAGUE. MENTION THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE OR
BUSINESSES THAT. HAVE MULTIPLE-
CHECKUPS OR- PRETTY QUALITY-
FAILURES TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE- BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE ALL CONDUCTING
BUSINESSES IN UNKNOWN TERRITORY
SOME OF THESE PLACES DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY'RE BREAKING- HEALTH
REQUIREMENT UNTIL IT IS BEING
PART FORTY BUT I DO RESPECT
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT ONCE THEY
ARE- NOTIFIED. THAT THEY DO IN
GOOD ILL AND GOOD FAITH DO
WHAT THEY CAN IN ORDER TO
REMEDY THOSE THOSE ARE FOR SO
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ANYONE ELSE ANY OTHER TAKERS ON
THE FLOOR AND- MAKES NO HANDS
UP LET ME GIVE YOU MY
PERSPECTIVE. YOU KNOW THIS IS
BETTER DIFFICULT MARCH. YOUR
TIME WITH THIS PANDEMIC AND IT
CONTINUES TO BE A DIFFICULT
MARCH. BUSINESS OWNERS ISSUE
WILL HAVE NOTED IN YOUR
COMMENTS OF. STRUGGLE TO COMPLY
WITH THE VARIOUS REGULATIONS
THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY THE
PANDEMIC OF NINETEEN.
REGULATIONS IN AN EVER CHANGING
ENVIRONMENT. AND EVER CHANGING
TEARS FRANKLY IN THE STATE UP
AND DOWN- AS YOU KNOW FROM
READING THE BILL I'M SURE THAT
THIS BILL. INVOLVES MORE THAN
JUST BARS AND RESTAURANTS
BUSINESSES THAT ARE IN
REGULATED BY THE- BY THE ABC-
IT INVOLVES. THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND SINCE
YOU'RE SITTING IN THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE YOU KNOW
THAT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
DIFFERENT TYPES OF BUSINESSES
AND TWO HUNDRED DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES AND PROFESSIONS. NOW
THE HEALTH CARE. ENTERPRISES
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. BUT
BARBERS AND COSMETOLOGISTS
LEAST IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OR
NOT AND THEY'RE PROBABLY MANY
OTHERS THAT ARE BURIED IN THAT
LIST OF DCA REGULATED.
OCCUPATIONS AND BUSINESSES THAT
ARE ALSO- NOT EXCLUDED. WE'VE
HAD STATE EMPLOYEES WORKING
DILIGENTLY UP AND DOWN THE
STATE TRYING TO ENFORCE THE
RULES THAT WE'VE PUT IN PLACE
THE RULES THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PUT IN PLACE THE REGULATIONS
THAT ARE STATE AGENCIES HAVE
ADOPTED. TO COMPLY WITH THIS
PANDEMIC- AND THERE'S NO SHORT
SNOW SHORT CITING THAT VERY
VERY DILIGENT VERY VERY
DEDICATED STATE EMPLOYEES ALSO
TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS.
PANDEMIC I DO WANNA THANK. THE
SENATOR AND THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US TO TRY TO
NARROW THIS BILL IN THE FAIRLY
SHORT TIME. THAT WE HAD TO DO
IT REMEMBER THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING FOR THIS BILL
AND- IF IT HAPPENS TO MOVE OUT
OF HERE WHICH MAY NOT HAPPEN
BUT IF IT DOES THERE ARE OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS- BOTH IN
THIS HOUSE AND IN THE HOUSE
DOWN THE HALL THAT. WILL HAVE
TO DEAL WITH THIS BILL-
OBVIOUSLY MORE DISCUSSION NEEDS
TO BE HAD ON THE DETAILS AND
THE ISSUES TO DEFINE
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE AMONG
OTHERS IF THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD BUT FRANKLY COLLEAGUES
FROM YOUR COMMENTS ON THE FLOOR
WHAT YOU HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR THOSE LISTENING IS A
IS THE DEFINITION OF
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE AUTHOR HAS
NOT HAD THE TIME THAT SOME OF
YOU HAVE OBVIOUSLY SPENT. TO
DEFINE SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DO YOU GET FIVE
BITES AT THE APPLE OR DO YOU
GET TO AND IS THE SECOND ONE
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE OR IS IT
ONE. YOU KNOW FOR A LONG TIME
IN THIS SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THAT'S NOW
GOING ON NINE YEARS. I'VE
THOUGHT THAT IN MOST CASES NOT
ALL. A SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
SHOULD BE AN INTEGRAL PART OF
OUR CALIFORNIA REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS GENERALLY
NOT IT'S- AN I GOTCHA SITUATION
IN MANY CASES ON THE ONLY.
CONSEQUENCE OF THE GOTCHA IS
HOW SEVERE THE PENALTY IS. AND
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE. AND THIS
BILL BEGINS TO EMBED
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE IN A
REGULATORY SCHEME. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO ARGUE AS MANY OF
US HAVE ON THE AFFIRMATIVE
SIDE. THAT SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE SHOULD BE THE
STANDARD IN SOME AREAS OF
BUSINESS REGULATION WHETHER
IT'S WAGING OUR OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH OR ANYTHING
ELSE. BUT NOT OTHERS. NOW
OBVIOUSLY YOU OUR ENTITLED TO
VOTE YOUR CONSCIENCE AND VOTE
THE WAY YOU READ THIS BILL AND
THAT'S THE WAY I AM IS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
WAY I'VE BEEN AS A CHAIR OF ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE THAT I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF HOLDING IN THE
EIGHT PLUS YEARS I'VE- BEEN
HERE. THIS BILL NEEDS MORE
WORK. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WILLING TO PUT INTHE WORK AND
MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
GOOD FOR THOSE THAT DON'T SEE
THE POSSIBILITY OF THAT THAT'S
FINE TOO. BUT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. BUT TODAY
WITH MY IPHONE. SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WORDS ON THE BILL AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO MAKING CHANGES AND AS
YOU INDICATED- THE THIS BILL
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE HEARD DURING
OUR LAST COMMITTEE HEARING I
PULLED IT. SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY DRILL DOWN AND WORK ON
THE DETAILS OF THIS BILL AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE GET IT RIGHT
WHICH I BELIEVE WE DID BUT OF
COURSE AS WE GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS WE MAY NEED TO REFINE
IT. MORE WHICH I'M WILLING TO
DO AND I AM CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING. WITH THE
OTHER SENATORS WHO MAYBE
MEMBERS OF THESE OTHER
COMMITTEES. SO THAT WE CAN
REFINANCE MORE AM NOT OPPOSED
TO THAT IF I WERE I WOULDN'T
HAVE PULLED THE BILL. IN THE
FIRST PLACE BUT I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT AS WELL THAT. THERE
WAS DISCUSSION ABOUT TAKING-
COVETED SERIOUSLY IN TAKING
THAT THE- TRANSMISSION OF THE
VIRUS SERIOUSLY. AND I THINK WE
ALL DO THAT BUT I THINK WE ALL.
ALSO KNOW THAT THE CDC HAS
ALREADY DONE THEIR STUDY AND
INDICATED. THAT SOMEONES IN
RESTAURANTS AND BARS WERE NOT
AFFECT THE LARGEST VECTORS. AT
THE TRANSMISSIONS OF THE VIRUS
AND FRANKLY IT WAS REALLY.
PRIVATE GATHERINGS THAT WERE
THE LARGEST PROBLEM NOT THE
TYPES OF. BUSINESSES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. SO I WOULD
ASK THAT YOU GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER REFINE
THIS BILL AND WORK WITH YOU. ON
THIS ISSUE SO THAT WE CAN. MAKE
SURE WE DON'T SEE EVEN MORE
PEOPLE HAVE THEIR LIVELIHOODS
GO UP IN SMOKE AND THEN HAVE TO
TELL THEIR EMPLOYEES. THEY NO
LONGER HAVE A JOB- EITHER IN
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SODO WE A MOTOR. ON THIS
BILL S. B. ONE OF ONE ZERO TWO.
USING. SERVER TILOS MOVE THE
BILL THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. YEAH FILE ITEM NINE
SENATE BILL ONE ZERO TWO TWO
PASSES AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION ROTH. ROTH AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE
ARCHULETA BEAT HI BATES AYE
BAKER NO BAKER NOTE DODD NAY
DODD NAY EGGMAN NO EGGMAN KNOW
HER TADO LINE FOR TAUGHT A WIDE
JONES HI. SO I LEAVE A NO LEE A
NOTE. NO MAN NO. NO NEWMAN NO
ACTUALLY ABODE HI A CHECK OF
GUIDE CAN. HAN. THE VOTERS FIVE
AND SEVEN KNOWS WILL HOLD ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. SURE.
SENATOR SKINNER SB. FIVE TO
FOUR. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- PLEASE TO PRESENT SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR AND LET ME
START WHICH INDICATING THAT I
AM ACCEPTING BOTH AMENDMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS- BUT I
WOULD LIKE YOUR PERMISSION TO
ON THE SECOND AMENDMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF
TO WORK ON THE LANGUAGE AS WE
HAVEN'T LANDED YET A LANGUAGE
THAT FULLY WORKS AND I GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK THAT
THE STAFF AND THE CHAIR OF DONE
SO FAR. IN- THIS BILL. SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR. WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS. GIVE FOLKS THE ABILITY
TO CHOOSE. THEIR PHARMACY. AND
YOU'D THINK THAT RIGHT NOW
PEOPLEHAVE THAT RIGHT BUT
SOMETIMES PATIENTS ARE STEERED
AWAY FROM THEIR CHOSEN PHARMACY
WHEN A PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER. INFORMS THEM THAT THEY
MUST FILL THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS
AT A PARTICULAR PHARMACY. OR
PAY OUT OF POCKET. NO THE BILL
DOES NOT MEAN THAT YOU WOULD
NECESSARILY HAVE YOUR FULL
COSTS COVERED IF YOU GO OUT OF
NETWORK YOU KNOW. THE PHARMACY
WOULD STILL NEED TO BE IN
NETWORK BUT THE PATIENT WOULD
BE ABLE TO CHOOSE THE PHARMACY
OF THEIR PREFERENCE. AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS IS THAT.
VERY OFTEN. EIGHT A PATIENT HAS
A LONG TERM RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PARTICULAR PHARMACIST AND
THAT PHARMACY HAD KNOWS THAT
PERSON'S MEDICAL HISTORY MAYBE
THERE'S CULTURAL SENSITIVITIES
MAYBE THERE'S A LANGUAGE
ISSUES. AND WHEN YOU CAN NOT
CHOOSE THE PHARMACY THAT YOU
WANT TO HAVE YOUR PRESCRIPTION
FILLED IN YOUR STEERED TO ONE
BY A PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER
YOU LOSE THOSE BENEFITS
ADDITIONALLY. THE PHARMACY THAT
YOU'RE STEER TO MAYBE FAR AWAY
FROM WHERE YOU LIVE. AND THERE
MAY BE OTHER ISSUES SO WHAT SB
FIFTY FIVE TWO FOUR DOES HIS
PROHIBITS PATIENTS FROM BEING
REQUIRED TO GO TO A PARTICULAR
PHARMACY WHEN THERE'S NO
CLINICAL REASON THAT THEY MUST
DO SO. AND ENSURES THAT
PATIENTS CAN ACCESS WHICH EVER
PHARMACY THEY PREFER WITHIN
THEIR NETWORK- AND WITH THAT IT
WOULD ALLOW MY- SPEAK AND I
HAVE JIM GROSS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION. AND CRAIG
PULSIPHER FROM AP LA HEALTH
WHICH IS A- HEALTH CENTER AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION SERVING
HIV PATIENTS IN LOS ANGELES
GENTLEMAN YOU MAY PROCEED
PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF OUR TIME
LIMITATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER TEACHES JIM
GROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION AS A SENATOR
INDICATED THE PURPOSES OF SB
FIVE TO FOUR. IT'S BEEN HEALTH
INSURERS PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER CONGLOMERATES FROM
DENYING PATIENTS A CHOICE OF
PHARMACY ISSUES FOR FILLING
PRESCRIPTIONS AND RECEIVING
SERVICES. THESE CONGLOMERATES
OF STEERING PATIENTS AWAY FROM
FARMERS USE THAT PATIENTS ARE
CONTRACTUALLY ENTITLED THE USE
IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE PROFITS
THEY CLAIM THEY'RE SAVING MONEY
BUT UNLESS THE PATIENT DIRECTLY
RECEIVES A FINANCIAL BENEFIT.
BY USING THE CONGLOMERATE'S
MAIL ORDER OR CHAIN PHARMACY
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
PATIENT BENEFITS FROM THIS.
CLARIFICATION IS DENIED CHOICE
THE PHARMACY HAS A CONTRACT
WITH THE CONGLOMERATE THE
PATIENT'S ENTITLED TO SEE THE
PHARMACY. AND SHOULD NOT BE
DENIED THE RIGHT ABSENT IN THE
STABBINGS CLINICAL LOGISTICAL
REASON. IF THE GLAMOUR WHICH IS
TO FINANCIALLY INCENTIVIZE
PATIENTS USE PHARMACY THE
AMENDMENT IDENTIFIED IN THE
ANALYSIS ALLOWS OUT. THE BILL
ALSO IN SIENA COMPETITIVE
PRACTICE OF ALLOWING THESE
CONGLOMERATES THE ABILITY TO
DESIGN A PRESCRIPTION DRUG
BENEFIT OFFERED TO SHOP THE
CURRENT PLAYERS THAT ONLY
OFFERS THE CONGLOMERATE'S
PHARMACIES AS AUTHORIZED
PHARMACIES FOR AN- INSURER SHE
YOU. THE ACT THAT IS NOT A
PRACTICE THAT IS ALLOWED UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S KNOCKS KEEN OUT
AND SO BELT PLANTS ARE
OPERATING UNDER A KNOCKS KEEN
ACT MUST HAVE BEEN ADEQUATE
NETWORK OF PHARMACIES WHICH TO
INCLUDE. MAIL ORDER AND- RETAIL
PHARMACY JUST THE DESIGN OF A
BENEFIT FOR THOSE IN CALIFORNIA
WILL NOT SHIP TO THE KNOX KEEN
ACT. THAT ONLY OFFERS MAIL
ORDER IS INCONSISTENT. WITH
CALIFORNIA POLICY. REGIMENTS
THAT B. GOOGLE IN TO TAKE IT OF
ALL SPOTS. AND THE PAY OF
INSURE COVER- BLACK BAR
POSITION TO LIVE CHOICE. AND
SECURE ALL RLAY REVENUE TO
COME. MITCHELL THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CALL OF DRUG. SB
FIVE TWENTY NEARLY I. TO LAWS
IN THIS INTEREST. ARKANSAS AND
JEFF RECENTLY CON. AND IT'S
COULD BE CONTRARY TO. SOME
COMMUTING HUMANE SEEN HAVE BEEN
BACK BY THE REUNION BY READ YOU
HAVE SUPPORTED DECISION. THAT
STATES THAT THEY DID NOT BY A
RISK HE'S PREPARED SPEECH.
THANK YOU YOU I WILL ASK YOU
AYE VOEPEL AVAILABLE QUESTION.
THANK YOU. THIS CALL. FOR A
GOOD MORNING MR CHU MEMBERS
CRAIG TO PER THE FUTURE OF
AFFAIRS A CHELATE AND ACCURACY
IN ONE OF THE LARGE H. SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND I LIKE HOW- I
JUST WANT TO BOOK IT BUT THE-
ON HOW PATIENTS HEARING IN MAIL
ORDER REQUIRE. IN PEOPLE WITH
HIV. I THINK MOST OF IT
DESTROYED. A REAL CRITICAL
REALLY. BETWEEN AND THEIR FARM
THAT. FOR MANY PATIENTS THEY
DEPEND ON THIS RELATIONSHIP
SOMETIME ON MONDAY KNOWN. FOR
YEARS. VIDAK: INFORMATION ON
SIDE EFFECTS. ENTER MY AT YOUR
END TO THE MEDICATION WHICH OF
IS. IMPORTANT FOR POPULAR.
DURING CAN ALSO CREATE REALLY
PICKING UP PRIDE ISSUE.
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ARE THOSE IN MORE
RURAL AREAS. IT NEEDS FOLKS
CAN'T PICK UP THEIR MEDICATION
AT THE PHARMACY OF CHOICE AND
ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO USE MAIL ORDER. SOMEONE
COULD FIND OUT ABOUT THEIR
MEDICAL CONDITION WHICH OF
COURSE COULD HAVE DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES. AND IT AT
PRECISELY FOR THESE REASONS
THAT MAIL ORDER REQUIREMENTS
HAVE LONG BEEN RECOGNIZED TO BE
AN APPROPRIATE AND EVEN
UNLAWFUL FOR PEOPLE WITH HIV.
AND LAST YEAR I JUST WNT TO
STRESS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PATIENTS BEING ABLE TO GO TO A
PHARMACY WHERE THEY FEEL SAFE.
AND WHERE THEY'LL BE TREATED
WITH RESPECT NOT HAVING A
CULTURALLY COMPETENT PROVIDERS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST REASONS
PEOPLE FALL OUT OF CARE.
ESPECIALLY FOR LGBT FOLKS
COMPLETED THE COLOR AND PATIENT
MUST BE GIVEN THE RIGHT TO
RECEIVE MEDICATIONS FROM
APARTMENTS FROM A PHARMACY OR
THEY FEEL WELCOMED AND
RESPECTED- XBLA HELD STRONGLY
SUPPORTS BY TWENTY FOUR AND-
GET YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WHEN I MOVED
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY IN
SUPPORT I SEE NONE WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE TO FOUR I SEE. NO
WITNESSES THERE LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE URBIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL FIVE TO FOUR. WILL PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. PLAYS
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. PLEASE
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PRESS ONE BUTTON. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK FINE
LET'S NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION- IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- THIS BILL
HEAD AND NECK. POLICE OFFICER
ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. GERMAN REMEMBER OUR
TIME CONSTRAINTS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MY
NAME IS BELLA HAD WITH PCMA WE
ARE THE NATIONAL PBM TRADE
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING THANK YOU TO SENATOR
SKINNER WHO HAS KEPT A BURKE
FOR ORPHANED OR AND LISTENING
TO OUR QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL I REMEMBER THIS
PRIMARILY ON MAIL ORDER- GIVEN
THE LAST IMAGE COMMENTS- MORE
THAN TEN MILLION RESIDENTS ARE
THROUGH MAIL ORDER PHARMACIES.
HMM CALIFORNIA EIGHT TWENTY
FOURTEEN STUDY BAG BE SIGNED A
INDEPENDENT CONSULTING. FIRM-
THAT MAIL ORDERS CAL. FIVE
DOLLARS OVER A TEN YEAR. MIDDLE
FACILITIES HAVE HIGHER AND HERE
RATES AND BECAUSE OF THE-
REDUNDANCY- IN WHICH
DESCRIPTIONS OF GENERAL MAIL
ORDER PHARMACY ARE TOP HAVE A
TO THREE PER HIGHER. ACCURACY
RATE- BROKEN WATER. WHEN WE IS
THAT MALE FOR SOME HAVE
PROMISED AND NURSES. AVAILABLE
FIRST SO THE PAGE HAS ADVERSELY.
A QUESTION ABOUT THE- WE ARE
ABLE TALK TO SOMEBODY WITH OF
THAT A TWENTY FOUR HOUR A DAY.
I THINK THIS IS A SPECIAL IN
THE MAIL ESPECIALLY MALES
SECTOR WHICH OFTEN VERY- THEM.
I TOUCH ASSEMBLY DRUGS BUT
REQUIRE SPECIAL IN THE MINISTRY.
AND BEING ABLE TO SOME TWENTY
FIRST. WHO SPENT IN THAT
DISEASE A PHARMACIST OR NURSE
WHO CAN. CAPITATION TO BROADEN
THE MINISTRATION AND OFTEN THE
DISPOSAL OF- THE SYRINGE IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT AND THE SPECIAL
MAIL FACILITIES ARE NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED BY OFTEN TWO OR MORE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS. WHICH
ALSO GOES TO- IMPORTANCE OF
PATIENT QUALITY. I SURE
WHATEVER REMAINED OF MY TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WITH NEXT.
THANK YOU MISTER MA'AM. NICKEL
THOSE WITH. ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS. WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SB FIVE
TWENTY FOUR- WE AGREE WITH MANY
OF THE ARGUMENTS- FROM PCA.
THE BILL USUALLY IN ITS CURRENT
FORM DEFINES PATIENTS STEERING
IN A WAY THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
HEALTH MODELS STEVEN COLORS
MONEY AND CONSUMERS MONEY FOR
THAT MATTER IN SOME HEALTH
PLANS ARE ARE PART OF THOSE
INTEGRATED MODELS- YOU KNOW
WHAT WE WERE INTERESTED IN THE
DATA THAT SUPPORTERS ARE
RELYING ON SHOW THAT THESE
INTEGRATED SYSTEMS RESTRICT
PATIENT CHOICE- WHEN- YOU KNOW
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE. SHOWN
THE OPPOSITE- IN STUDIES OF
THOSE SYSTEMS BY THE FEDERAL
TRADE COMMISSION AND OTHERS
HAVE FOUND THAT THESE-
INTEGRATED. MODELS CAN LOWER
COSTS FOR CONSUMERS- SO WE CAN
GET WE BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE TO EMPLOYERS ARE
LOOKING TO ACHIEVE. THE RIGHT
PRICE POINT TO PROVIDE COVERAGE
FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES- NOW HAVING
SAID THAT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
AMENDMENTS ARE IN THE WORK AND-
WILL CERTAINLY ANALYZE THOSE
ONES- THE AUTHOR- ON LAND ON
THE LANGUAGE- AND MOVE FORWARD
ACCORDINGLY ONCE WE HAVE HAD A
TIME. TO REVIEW THOSE
AMENDMENTS- BUT AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME- WE DO
REMAIN OPPOSED TO THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LET'S
SERVING. SEE IF THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE THE C.
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
THERE SITTING NO WITNESSES
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF THIS MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY WILL PROCEED.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I GET AND THE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT
NOW GOING GO TO MINE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JOHN LINGER ON BEHALF
OF AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
PLANS ALSO RESPECTFULLY
APPROACHED. NEXT NOW GO TO LINE.
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
TREAT THE START WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE HEY WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD THUS
FAR I WITH THE AUTHOR THAT THE
DOCTOR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF-
TO RESOLVE OUR CONCERNS WE
BELIEVE WE CAN FINALIZE
RESOLUTION ON THAT VERY SOON
BUT AT THE TIME WE REMAIN
OPPOSED APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION. NECKLINE BUT WHEN
THE NINE. YES GOOD MORNING
PRESS TWO YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NEXT MISTER CHAIR THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE THAT SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU. CENTER
BEFORE I FORGET TO I MAY HAVE
NOT A MAYBE I DIDN'T HEAR IT
DID YOU ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS YES
THANK YOU TERRY OPEN TO MY
COMMENTS WITH- ACCEPTING BOTH
AMENDMENTS HOWEVER ASKING YOUR
PERMISSION. TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF TO DAWN THE
LANGUAGE FOR THE SECOND ONE.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
THERE LEYVA THANK YOU MISTER
TECH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
I HAVE RECEIVED THOSE LETTERS
IN THE PAST TRYING TO STEER ME
TO A DIFFERENT PHARMACY AND I
THINK AS NOTED BY THE AUTHOR
THERE ARE PEOPLE BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PHARMACISTS AND IF THEY CHOOSE
TO CHANGE PHARMACIES THAT
SHOULD BE THE PATIENTS CHOICE
NOT THEIR PBMS CHOICE SO I AM
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND
MOVE IT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK CENTER LEVENS THERE
NEWMAN. HE MATURES I WOULD
AGREE THAT- PATIENTS IN MANY
INSTANCES- IS A PROBLEMATIC
THING LIKE I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR- A COUPLE OF THE
WITNESSES PROPOSED INCLUDING MR
LEWIS HAVE NOTED. THAT MANY
HEALTHCARE PLANS ACTUALLY DO
ENJOY SAVINGS- PARTICULAR ON
MAINTENANCE DRUGS WHERE THERE
PROBABLY ISN'T A NEED FOR A DAY
DIRECT PHARMACIST PATIENT
CONSULTATIONS. I TRY NOT CLEAR
ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
GOT- THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING
THE FUTURE- BUT I WOULD HOPE
THAT THERE'S SOME MIDDLE GROUND
THERE- FOR A FAIRLY NARROW USE
CASE. WHERE IF YOU HAVE ANY TO
DESCRIBE AND IF YOU CAN PROVE
OR IF THERE'S SOME INSURANCE-
THAT THE CUSTOMER FOR PATIENTS
RECEIVING THE BEST PRICE- BUT
THAT WOULD STILL BE ACCEPTABLE
SO IF YOU. COULD SPEAK TO THAT
I'D BE GRATEFUL- WITH THROUGH
THE CHAIR. YES PLEASE- THANK
YOU FOR THE- SO THERE'S- FIVE
THERE. NOT ONLY THE BILL'S
CONSTRUCTED BUT ALSO WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THERE IS NOTHING
THAT WOULD PROHIBIT SAY THE-
PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGER. FROM
DISCOUNTING FROM YOU KNOW
COMMUTE CLEARLY COMMUNICATING
TO THE CONSUMER THAT- PHARMACY
X. WOULD GIVE THE PRESCRIPTION
AT A LOWER PRICE THERE'S
NOTHING THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
THAT. IT JUST PROHIBITS
INDICATING THAT YOU COULD ONLY
USE THAT PHARMACY SO IF THE
PATIENT CHOOSES FOR EXAMPLE TO
HAVE TO YOU KNOW PAY A HIGHER
COPAY OR PAVE FURTHER OUT OF
POCKET. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
IT BUT IT DOES NOT LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR DEAN BENEFITS
MANAGER TO NEGOTIATE A
DIFFERENT PRICE WITH THEIR
PREFERRED AND AGAIN YOU JUST
WENT THERE SO THAT THE UNIT IS
JUST AFFECTING THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN OPT IN AND OPT OUT
THEN- WHERE THE- THE PATIENT.
WOULD HAVE TO FIRMLY OPT IN TO
A PROGRAM IS SUPPOSED TO WEAR
THE HEALTH PLAN COULD GIVE THEM
THE OPTION OF OPTING OUT WELL
IT'S NOT SO MUCH OPT IN OR OPT
OUT RIGHT NOW CERTAIN OF THESE
BENEFITS MANAGERS ARE BASICALLY.
COMMUNICATE TO THE PATIENTS
THAT YOU HAVE NO CHOICE YOU CAN
ONLY USE PHARMACY X. AND SO
WHAT THIS WOULD ALLOW IS THAT
YOU COULD USE WHICHEVER
PHARMACY YOU CHOOSE WITHIN THAT
NETWORK. THE PATIENT BENEFIT
MANAGER THE PRESCRIPTION THAT
MAKES COMMUNICATE THAT THERE'S
THIS ADVANTAGE TO X. OR Y. AND
THEN YOU COULD CHOOSE TO DO
THAT IF YOU CHOSE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BUT YOU WOULD NOT BE
FORCED TO. SHOW ACTION ISSUE
RIGHT I DO APPRECIATE IT ONE OF
THE MOST TROUBLING ASPECTS OF
OUR INSURANCE COULD SYSTEM AS
IT EXISTS IS THE- PICK THE
OPACITY OF PAYMENT. RIGHT SO
ALL THINGS BEING EQUAL
CUSTOMERS OR PATIENTS TO MAKE
DECISIONS- THAT OFTEN- WILL NOT
BE WITH RESPECT TO PRICE- YOU
KNOW WE'VE HAD. THE LEVERAGE
OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS TO
PRODUCE TRêN- BUT IT IS TRUE.
THAT THERE PROBABLY ARE ALL
BEING EQUAL A CLUB- CHIU FOR
DELIVERING SHOULD THE
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT ONE IS.
CHEAPER AND SO I WOULD MAKE
SURE. LEAST HAVE INSURANCE-
THAT WE DON'T FOR GO THAT
POSSIBILITY AS PART OF THIS
BILL. FROM THE INTEREST THING
ABOUT THIS AS WELL WELL
SOMEBODY OPPOSITION MIGHT
CLAIM. THAT THERE. THAT THE ARE
STEERING. TO A PARTICULAR CHAIN
FOR EXAMPLE LIKE SHE SHE SAID
AS AN EXAMPLE. IT IS BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO GREATLY REDUCE
COSTS AND THUS BE LESS BURDEN
ON ALL OF US SINCE ALL OF US IN
FACT- INSURANCE IS A IS A POOL.
SO ALL OF A SHARE IN THE COST
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT IN
FACT ANY OF THEIR STEERING HAS
REDUCED ALL OF OUR COSTS AND
WHAT IN FACT WE'VE SEEN IS THAT
VERY OFTEN THE PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER IS STEERING. TO THE
CLUSTER PHARMACIES THAT IS
PHONE THAT THE IN OTHER WORDS
THE ENTITY. THAT OPERATES
PHARMACIES ALSO OWNS THE
PHARMACY BENEFITS MANAGER. VERY
BAD AND YOU KNOW IT SEEMS TO
ME. THAT- THOSE PREMIUMS ARE
OPERATE MAIL ORDER FACILITIES
COULD PROVIDE EVIDENCE IN SOME
FASHION AT THE GIVING THE
CUSTOMER THE CHEAPEST PRICE AT
THE END THROUGH THAT HEALTH
PLAN SAVING. ALL OF US MONEY
AND SO AGAIN MY HOPE IS THAT WE
DON'T WE DON'T ELIMINATE THAT
POSSIBILITY FOR LEGISLATION I
CERTAINLY WOULD NOT WANT TO
PRECLUDE THAT AND- CERTAINLY
THE WHOLE ISSUE OF HOW WE
CONTROL COSTS WITHIN. OUR
HEALTH- DELIVERY SYSTEM IN OUR
INSURANCE IS SEPARATE FROM THIS
BILL WELL I THINK THE
OPPOSITION'S CLOUDING THE ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING
SPECIFIC IN THIS BILL THAT
WOULD EITHER GUARANTEE A
REDUCED COST. OR PREVENT. THANK
YOU CENTER CHIPS KENNARD THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU SIR NEWMAN
SIR EDMUND. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CENTER. I HAVE A QUESTION
I LIKE TO SPELL ON I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THIS BILL AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT- AT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO MIGHT BE SELF
INSURED AND THEN USE A PBM FOR
COST SAVINGS WHEN I WAS IN A
STOCKTON CITY COUNCIL USED ONE
AND I USED A SMALL MOM AND POP
PHARMACY THAT IS SADLY NOW GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS BUT IT IT- IT
IT JUST DID MAIL ORDER OR JUST
SOME OF THE BIG CHANGE AN
ARGUMENT WAS FOR A COST SAVINGS
BECAUSE OF COULD YOU SPEAK A
LITTLE. ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THEIR ROLES IN AND BE USING
PBMS. SO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
AMONG THE EMPLOYERS THAT USE
PBMS. AND THIS AGAIN WOULD- NOT
PREVENT THEM FROM DOING SO. AND
IT WOULD STILL ALLOW THE PBM TO
COMMUNICATE TO THE PATIENT WHAT
A PREFERRED PHARMACY IS OR WHAT
A FARM A PHARMACY THAT MIGHT
GIVE THEM A DISCOUNT. FOR
EXAMPLE. IN THIS ALSO WOULD
STILL REQUIRE THE PATIENT TO
USE A PHARMACY WITHIN A
NETWORK. SO IT IT ISN'T THAT
YOU WOULD GET TO YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY GO OUT OF NETWORK
AND EXPECT. YOUR INSURER TO
COVER THAT COST- SO IT. IT IN A
WAY IT'S KIND OF A HYBRID IN
THAT. IT WOULD IT JUST.
PREVENTS THE PBM FROM.
SPECIFYING THAT YOU CAN ONLY
USE PHARMACY X. SEARCH LOCAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WOULD
FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE FORWARD AND PERSONS
HERE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND MAKE
THIS WORK- BILL WORKABLE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. IT APPEARS
FROM THE DISCUSSIONS TODAY
THAT- AND FROM THE AMENDMENTS
OFFERED THAT YOUR GOAL IS NOT
TO PREVENT. THE TBMS FROM
SETTING UP THESE PREFERRED
NETWORKS AND A COST SAVING
OPTION FOR CONSUMERS SO LONG AS
IT IS AN OPTION NOT A REGULAR
REQUIREMENTS IS THIS CORRECT.
THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING- IF
YOU DON'T MIND WHY DON'T YOU
ASK THEM- YOUR SET OF QUESTIONS
AND THEN IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT I. FUEL LESS- THAT I MIGHT
CONFUSE IN TERMS OF ANSWERING I
COULD ASK JIM GROSS TOO- TO
CLARIFY ADDITION. AND THEN- SO
ARE WE DID YOU I'M SORRY I
THOUGHT IF YOU WOULD LIST YOUR
QUESTIONS THEN I CAN SEE- I
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ANSWER THEM
ALL OR WHETHER I WOULD LIKE JIM
GROSS TO ALSO JOIN I
UNDERSTAND- IS THAT ALSO YOUR
GOAL TO ALLOW THE PBMC
COMMUNICATE TO CONSUMERS THE
SAVINGS THAT MIGHT COME ALONG.
WITH USING PREFERRED NETWORKS.
AND LASTLY- I JUST WANT TO
COMMEND AND PERSONAL LEVEL THE
FACT THAT THIS IS JUST GIVING
CONSUMERS OPTIONS FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S AN ADVOCATE FOR GIVING
CONSUMERS OPTIONS AND CHOICES I
TRULY APPRECIATE THE EFFORT AND
INTENT. OF THE BILL IN THAT
EFFORT. THANK YOU- IT. IT THE
INTENT IS AS I INDICATED BEFORE
TO BE ABLE TO GIVE THAT THE
ABILITY FOR THE PATIENT OF
CHOICE BUT IT DOES NOT PROHIBIT
THE BENEFIT MANAGER FROM
COMMUNICATING WHERE THERE MAY
BE A DISCOUNT INVOLVED BUT
ALLOW ME TO HAVE- JIM GROSS
ADD. TO ANSWERS TO ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU RAISED IN
CASE I HAVE NOT BEEN IS
COMPLETE. IS THAT- OKAY SHARE.
YES MISTER GROSS. HOPEFULLY
HE'S STILL ON THE LINE MR
GROCERY USED TO ONLINE THE- WE
AT LEAST GET INTO WE DO BELIEVE
DOES GIVE THE HEALTH PLANS IN
THE PHARMACY BENEFIT MANAGERS
THE ABILITY TO ONE APPLE FOR
NETWORKS BUT NOT ONE. THAT ONLY
INVOLVE THOSE IN- PHARMACIES
AND MAIL ORDER IN WHICH THEY
HAVE TOTAL OWNERSHIP AND
CONTROL SECOND- WITH RESPECT TO
THE STEERING INTO SPECIFICALLY
THE AMENDMENT THAT THE SENATOR
CLOCK AND OUR INTENTION IS TO
ALLOW AND EVEN. TECHNOLOGY
APPROPRIATENESS OF OFFERING
DISCOUNTS AND OTHER BENEFITS TO
ENTICE THE PATIENT TO GO TO A
PARTICULAR PHARMACY AND SO WITH
A MAIL ORDER PHARMACY- WILL
OFFER A LOWER COPAY OR
SOMETHING THAT DIRECTLY- DRIVE
STREET THE PATIENTS BENEFIT
THAT IS PERFECTLY ACCEPTABLE
BECAUSE NOT ONLY THAT PART
BECAUSE THEY CAN LOWER
HEALTHCARE COSTS. BUT THESE
MANDATORY NETWORKS THAT DO NOT
PROVIDE THAT AND THE STEERING
THAT TAKE YOU AWAY FROM A
PHARMACY THAT YOU USE WITHOUT
RESPECT TO WHETHER THERE'S ANY
DIRECT FINANCIAL BENEFIT THAT
AS. WITH THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO PROHIBIT. SO WITH COMMITMENT-
I WILL BE SERV THE BILL TO. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THE
BILL IMPROVE BY THE TIME HE
GETS THE FLOOR ROAD RESERVE MY
ABILITY TO BE CONSERVE MY BOAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR STINNER THANK
YOU SENATOR CENTER BACKER. I
WOULD THINK THE AUTHORS WILL
INTEREST A I'M I AM. PRO CHOICE
IN THIS MATTER AND I APPRECIATE
THAT- HER BRING THIS UP IN AND
GIVING. FOLKS THAT CHOICE AND
AGAIN AS WE WERE CLEAR. IT
DOESN'T RESTRICT ANYONE'S
ABILITY TO- TO OFFER BENEFITS
TO FOLKS- THAT THEY CHOOSE TO
OFFER- DISCOUNTS TO. DID YOU
DISCUSS KAISER AND HOW KAISER
FALLS INTO THIS. LET ME HAVE A
JIM GROSS RESPONDED THAT. GROSS
YES AND I THINK IT GETS KAISER
INDICATED WE ARE IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM ABOUT
HOW TO ADDRESS- COMMITTEE ON
SUCH AS YOU KNOW CONTROVERSIAL.
INTEGRATED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
WHEN YOU SIGNED UP FOR KAISER
YOU AGREE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
USE THEIR HOSPITAL. AND THEIR-
AFFILIATED PROVIDER NETWORK AND
SO THAT IS A CONSUMER CHOICE
RIGHT UP WITH ONE ABOUT BEING
WITHIN A AS WE CALL IT A CLOSED
NETWORK THAT IS NOT THE CASE
WHEN YOU SIGN UP FOR A HEALTH
PLAN AND LATER TO FIND OUT.
THEY'RE BEING OR THERE'S
RUNNING ARE PROBABLY BUT YOU
WERE NOT TOLD AND WE'RE NOT
HARD- YOU. WERE YOUR OWN CHOICE
AND SO I WAS USING DIFFERENT
ANIMAL IN THAT REGARD WE
BELIEVE- BECAUSE OF THE WAR
UNDERSTANDING OF BEING PART OF
A FULLY INTEGRATED NETWORK. NOT
BE PROHIBITED IN THAT REGARD WE
NEED TO WORK OUT AMENDMENTS
WITH KAISER ALONG THOSE LINES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- THE
OFFICER BAKER THANK YOU CENTER
DIED. YES I BELIEVE THAT-
SERVER NEWMAN'S QUESTIONS
ANSWERED A LOT OF MIND I
CONTINUE TO BE A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED JUST BECAUSE WE'RE
CONSTANTLY BARRAGED WITH
COMPLAINTS ABOUT PRESCRIPTION
PRICING AND SO YOU HAVE NOW WE
HAVE PLANS FOR COUNTIES PERHAPS
OUR STATE. THAT ARE TRYING
THEIR BEST TO CONTROL COSTS AND
HERE WE ARE. PUTTING UP SOME
LIMITATIONS TO THAT THAT SAID
WOULD YOU LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY OF THOSE SITES AS IS
OFTEN THE CASE IN BMP YOU CAN
FIVE ROOM ON BOTH SIDES TO.
REALLY UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
OF- THE TESTIMONY AGAIN ON BOTH
SIDES. IF THERE EVER IS AN
AUTHOR IN THE SENATE THE BUT I
BILL WILL- BE A WORK THROUGH
THE ISSUES IT'S SKINNER AND
ALSO BUILD. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR-
WAITED FOR DON'T CALL YOU
SAYING CENTER SKINNER YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU. ARMED I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION IN THE
AND I ALSO IF IT SHEARER THE OF.
OUR HEALTH CARE COSTS IN
PRESCRIPTION PRICES ESPECIALLY
WHAT I FIND VERY INTERESTING IS
THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST THIRTY TO FORTY YEARS. IS
A REAL SHRINKING OF A PHARMACY
AVAILABILITY WELL THERE THERE'S
A LOT OF PHARMACIES THEY ARE
PRIMARILY THE INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES. HAVE ALMOST
DISAPPEARED. NOW THE WEATHER IN
THE LOSS OF INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES AS AFFECTED
PRESCRIPTION COSTS OR NOT I
CAN'T BY DO NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE BUT CERTAINLY THE
CONSOLIDATION OF PHARMACIES TO
BEING THOSE PHARMACIES THAT ARE
THEN OWNED. THAT THE FOR THE
OWNERS OF THE PHARMACIES ALSO
OWNED THE PRESCRIPTION BENEFITS
MANAGERS DOES NOT SEEM TO
BENEFIT US IN TERMS OF
PRESCRIPTION COST NOW THAT TO
ME PROBABLY IS A DIFFERENT SET
OF LEGISLATION. THAT WE WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO LOOK AT AND
WHETHER EVEN THE STATE HAS THE
ABILITY TO. TO- MODIFY YOUR
INFLUENCE THOSE COSTS- AGAIN I
THAT IS NOT MY EXPERTISE BUT I
CERTAINLY FIND IT VERY
INTERESTING THAT ENTITIES LIKE
THE CHAMBER. WOULD OPPOSE SUCH
A BILL WHICH BASICALLY MY BILL
SUPPORTS BUSINESS. BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS FOR ANY BUSINESS THAT IS
WITH ANY PHARMACY BUSINESS THAT
IS WITHIN THE NETWORK TO BE
ABLE TO BE UTILIZED. AND NOT TO
BE IN A SITUATION WHERE THE
PRESCRIPTION BENEFITS MANAGER
DIRECTION YOU SOMEWHERE ELSE-
INTERESTINGLY- I GREW UP
WORKING FOR AN INDEPENDENT
PHARMACY MY FATHER WAS
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIST. HIS
BUSINESS HE HAS PASSED PEAS-
PASSED AWAY IN THE EARLY
NINETIES HOWEVER HIS BUSINESS
STILL HAS HIS NAME ON IT IS
STILL OPERATED BY A FAMILY THAT
EXISTS TODAY. NOW HOW THEY HAVE
EXISTED ALL THESE YEARS IS
PARTLY DUE TO THE FACT OF THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE THAT THAT
PHARMACY PROVIDED AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PATIENTS. AND PEOPLE PREFER ED
CHOOSING TO GO THERE REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCE WAS
REGARD IN TERMS OF WHERE THEY
WERE STEERED. ARM NOW THIS BILL
WAS NOT WRITTEN TO BENEFIT ONLY
OR SOLELY INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES THERE'S TOO FEW HAVE
TO HAVE TO REALLY CARRY A BILL
FOR THAT PURPOSE BUT IT
CERTAINLY ALLOWS FOR. THE
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO FOR
WHATEVER REASON WHETHER IT'S
CULTURAL WHETHER IT'S PRIVACY
WHETHER IT'S LANGUAGE WHETHER
IT'S RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PHARMACIST FOR WHATEVER REASON
BE ABLE TO HELP THEIR
PRESCRIPTION FILLED WHERE THEY
CHOOSE TO. A PHARMACY WITHIN
THEIR NETWORK AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. THIS BILL SENATE BILL
FIVE TWO FOUR. THURMOND DOES
MOVE THE BILL. MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE ON FILE ITEM TEN AT
THREE FIVE TWO FOUR DEEP PASSES
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH ROTHSTEIN. ROTH HI
MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA I URGE A
LOT I BEAT. ET FEB. OKAY BAKER
DODD I THOUGHT I EGGMAN. EGGMAN
AYE HER TADO. FOR TAUGHT AYE
ALRIGHT. LEYVA BY LEYVA FIVE
MEN BY MEN AYE NEWMAN. NEWMAN
AYE AYE CHAU ABODE HI A TURBO
GUIDE PAEAN. HI CAN I. THE BILL
HAS ELEVEN VOTES ENOUGH TO PASS
OUT OF COMMITTEE WILL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME
NUMBER. THAT TODAY IS THE LAST
BILL WE WILL HEAR SENATE BILL.
TWO FOUR ONE. CHAIR OF THE ONCE
AGAIN I'M BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE
AND THE- CHILDLINE I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOU AND YOUR
STAFF PARTICULARLY ALYSSA SILVA
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL- THIS IS A BILL DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF
OUR COURTS ARE THERE TO ASPECTS
OF THE BILL- FIRSTLY COURT
REPORTER BOARD WHICH IS
JURISDICTION OVER COURT
REPORTERS WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER OUT OF STATE
COURT REPORTERS AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS STAND WHICH IS
BASICALLY. A COURT REPORTER IN
CHARGE WHO IS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COURT
REPORTING BOARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEOUT OF STATE COURT
REPORTERS IT HERE TO CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS THAT'S POINT ONE
POINT TWO IS WITH RESPECT TO OF
WITNESSES TESTIFYING REMOTELY
AS THE CHAIR IS AWARE-
SOMETIMES THEIR MINISTER
WITNESSES IT APPEARED TRIAL FOR
EXAMPLE CUSTODIAN OF RECORDS IN
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT HAVE
BOTH PARTY STIPULATE YOUR
RESPECTIVE OF THE JUDGE'S
DECISION IF BOTH PARTIES
STIPULATE TO WITNESS TESTIFYING
REMOTELY THEY MAY DO SO. THE
END OF ONE PARTY WISHES TO HAVE
A WITNESS TESTIFIED REMOTELY
AND THE OTHER PARTY OBJECTS
THEN THE JUDGE HAS CERTAIN
CRITERIA THAT- SHE SHOULD USE
TO EVALUATE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
WITH THIS MAY TESTIFY REMOTELY-
IT WILL CREATE EFFICIENCIES AND
REDUCE EXPENSE ORIGINAL VOTE
ALSO WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN.
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS- IS. ONE
IS YVONNE FENNER EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA SENATOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
HELP ME OUT YES YVONNE FENNER
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE
COURT REPORTERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA IS ON IT ALSO- MISS
SABINA TO CAR LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED AND BE MINDFUL IF YOU
WILL OF OUR TIME LIMITATIONS.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS YVONNE
CENTER EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
COURT REPORTERS BOARD THANK YOU
CHAIR ROSS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU ABOUT AN
UNCOMPLICATED WELL VETTED.
FISCALLY SMART SOLUTION BEING
OFFERED IN SB TWO FORTY ONE
THAT WOULD ENSURE THAT ALL
CONSUMERS COURT REPORTING
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
PROTECTED. WHETHER THEY SIX FOR
THOSE SERVICES THROUGH A
LICENSEE OWNED FIRM OR
CORPORATION NOT OWNED BY A
LICENSEE. IT'S THAT SIMPLE IT'S
ABOUT CONSUMER PROTECTION.
REPORTERS TRANSCRIPT IS AN
IMPORTANT DOCUMENT BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER TRIAL
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LEADERS
HAVE PAINSTAKINGLY CRAFTED LAWS
TO INCLUDE DETAILS AND
SPECIFICITY ON EXACTLY HOW THE
RECORD SHOULD BE HANDLED. WILL
BE INTEGRITY OF COURT REPORTING
IN THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM WE ARE
HERE BEFORE YOU AS A BOARD
ABILITY. TO SERVE AND PROTECT
THE CONSUMERS HAVE BEEN IN BY
NOW BEING ABLE TO IN THE LAWS
COULD NOT FIELD. FOR COMPLAIN
THAT BOARD RECEIVED INCLUDE
BILLING THE REGULAR. ENTRANCE
MISCON BY ALLOW ONE FOR TO HAV
ACCESS TO IT. BEFORE THE L.
GIVING THEM ADVANTAGE PREPARE
FOR LIVE. THE BOARD HAS WORKED
CLOSE WITH YOU TO GENERAL
OFFICE. ON ARM OF THE- FOR
SIMPLEST FROM TO HOLD ALL
PROVIDERS OF COURSE REPORTING
SERVICE TO THE STANDARD
ESTABLISHED BY LEGISLATURE. NO
MATTER WHERE THEIR HOME STATE
IS LOCATED SB TWO FORTY ONE
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS TO
KNOW THEY HAD SOMEONE TO TURN
TO NAMELY THE COURT REPORTERS
BOARD SHOULD THEY EXPERIENCE ON
ETHICAL AND LEGAL BEHAVIOR BY A
COURT REPORTER FOR A COURT
REPORTING FIRM. THE WELCOME
DIVERSE IS. BECAUSE COMPETITION
IS GOOD FOR THE CONSUMER ITS
FIRST HEALTHY BUSINESS. RAISES
THE QUALITY OF PERFORMANCE
LOWERS PRICES AND EXPAND ACCESS
TO GOODS AND SERVICES. WHAT IS
NOT GOOD FOR THE CONSUMER IF
YOU HAVE THE BOARD UNABLE TO
STEP IN AND ENFORCE THE LAWS
THAT WERE GIVEN TO IT BY THE
LEGISLATURE. WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR ON BURKE AND HIS STAFF
FOR THEIR DEDICATION TO
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB TWO FORTY ONE FOR
EQUAL PROTECTION OF ALL
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN VERY FIFTEEN ATTACK
ARE WITH THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA ESTARá COOK
YOU'RE AT THE TWO FORTY ONE THE
BILL ALLOWS CERTAIN WITNESSES
TO APPEAR IN COURT BY LIVE
REMOTE VIDEO THERE IS NOTHING
NEW ABOUT REMOTE TESTIMONY IN
THE COURT HEARINGS HAVE BEEN
CONDUCTED AND REMOTELY FOR
EXAMPLE BY TELEPHONIC MEANS TO
COURT CALL FOR OVER A DECADE.
PREPAYMENT AN EXTRAORDINARILY
WITNESSES THAT ARE NOT PRIMARY
ARE CRITICAL BILL NOT THE PURE
IN COURT TESTIFYING WITNESSES
LINED THE HALLS OF THE COURT
PLEADING HALF A DAY OR ENTIRE
DATE BY FOR EXAMPLE I'D CENTER
UNDER MENTION IT COULD GET IN A
RECORD. IT IS DEEPLY CONCERNED
THE CONVENIENCE FOR THE
WITNESSES AT THE TWO FORTY ONE
WOULD ALLOW THE EQUIPMENT THAT
YOU'RE PURE BY LIVE REMOTE
VIDEO IN LIGHT OF THE CURRENT
CRISIS THE COURT DUE TO
PANDEMIC CLOSURES EVER GOING
BACK BECAUSE WE MUST EMBRACE
TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGICAL
EFFICIENCY. EFFICIENTLY BIKE AT
THE TWO FORTY ONE WILL ALSO BE
CRITICAL EVEN AFTER THE CRISIS
BY REMOTE BY WITNESSES ARE
CURRENTLY ALLOWED UPON
AGREEMENT OF THE PARTIES THE
JUDGE SB TWO FORTY ONE
SOLIDIFIED THE PRACTICES THAT
YOU CAN SHARE COURT CAN
FUNCTION EFFICIENTLY AND SAFETY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. TELL
EVERYBODY WHAT. IN THE- AND- I
SEE NO SUCH WHAT. ARE WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWELVE TO TELL. IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE TWO FOUR ONE.
SEEING LET'S TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO. VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING OF ISTHMUS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. WE WILL
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE BUTTONZERO. WE DO
HAVE- SEVERAL OF PARTICIPANT
SHOULD HAVE SIGNALED THEY WISH
TO SPEAK ONE MOMENT PLACE. WELL
NOW GO TO LINE. FIFTY SIX. I'M
NOT SURE IF THAT MEANS. THAT IS.
MY NAME IS JUNE OSBORNE
CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED SHORTHAND
REPORTER NUMBER ONE THREE THREE
ZERO EIGHT I AM A FREELANCE
COURT REPORTER COULD PROBABLY
SUPPORT AT TWO FORTY ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU PERFECT TIME NEXT
PLEASE. LINE. EIGHTY FIVE. YES
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME PERFECTLY S.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE LESLIE
I AM A CERTIFIED- FREELANCE
REPORTER AS WELL NUMBER ONE TWO
EIGHT NINE THREE AND I ALSO
PROBABLY SUPPORT SB TWO FOUR
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. LINE EIGHTY FOUR. IT'S
RETURN MEMBERS MIKE BELOW
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR NEXT PLEASE. PINE
EIGHTY SIX. YES YOU CAN GROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE DEPOSITION
REPORTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. FINE. FIFTY EIGHT- YES
HELLO THIS IS DIANE FRIEDMAN-
COURT RECORDER NUMBER. FIVE
PROUD FREELANCE REPORTER IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO STRONGLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU MA'AM NEXT
PLEASE. BLIND'S. SEVENTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
VERONICA GUERRERO A CALIFORNIA.
ORDER NUMBER ONE FOUR ONE THREE
NINE AND I AM A LEFT THE CORNER
PROBABLY SUPPORTING AT EACH ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE.
THE TEACHER THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE SIX SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NONE
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WHICH TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL TWO FORTY ONE I
SEE NO WITNESSES. LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST IN
OPPOSITION MR MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
WITNESSES. WE WILL PROCEED. FOR
THOSE O YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
THAT HAVE SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO LINE. THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS HER NUMBER
COULD NOT SERVE HERNANDEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTER. ATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION-
COULD BOTH PROVISIONS- IN
REGARDS TO THE DEPOSITION FROM
REGISTRATION WE ARE A LONG.
ACTIVE IN THE POSITION TO
SUPPORT ON THIS YEAR BEING THE
FORTY OVER. FOR HOWEVER THE WAY
THE BILL'S- THE MONEY ABOUT
SORT OF KERR BECAUSE OF
SOMEBODY OF THE YEAR TO. YOU
CAN GET A LOT STRONG ENOUGH WE
ARE. THE BILL TO BE STRONGER
AND ARE HAPPY TO COORDINATE
WITH THE SPONSORS AND AUTHOR TO
MAKE THE BUILD STRONGER AND
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS PROTECTED
IN THE RECORDS PROTECTED. BUT
AS OF NOW IS NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
IN IT TO THE PROVISION RELATED.
TO REMOTE. FOR INSTANCE IN THE
COURTROOM. THERE ARE ALREADY IN.
ORDER IN PLACE. FIVE WILL BE IN
PLACE FOR SIX MONTHS AFTER
LIFTING OF THIS- MARTIN TO
ORDER. AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE WORK
DONE AND WE DO. ABOUT OF
CURRENT. BEFORE WE- PUT IN
PLACE THE STAFF RELATED TO.
REMOTE APPEARANCE WITH THE
RISQUE RECORDS FROM. REPORTERS
A LOT OF. REMOTELY AND THOSE
PROBLEMS YES. DILATED BEFORE
MOVE ON SOCIAL TO THE MOVE ON.
THE TEMPORARY IS IN EFFECT WILL
BE THE FACT. OKAY THAT PROCESS
MONTH ABOUT THE STATEWIDE ORDER
INTERESTED. I'LL COVER THOSE.
WE DO NOT WORK OUT PROTECTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR PLEASE
RE. TO THOSE ON THE LINE PLEASE
UP IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AT TIMES
TO HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND
I'M SURE. YOU WANT. US ALL TO
HEAR YOU NEXT PLEASE. ONE
TWENTY SAID. CASH GOOD MORNING
MISS CARE AND MEMBER LED BAND
ON BEHALF OF S. YOU HELLO.
REPRESENTING COURT REPORTERS
WORKING INCOME COURTS THE AND
TO AT EIGHTEEN FORTY ONE- THE
QUESTION THAT YOU DISCLOSE THE
QUICKNESS IS ON THE TELEPHONE
HAVE SHOWN ANY MORE CLEARLY
WHAT I'M ABOUT TO SAY MY COURT
REPORTERS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC I'VE HAD GREAT
DIFFICULTY IN HEARING THE
SANCTITY AND INTEGRITY OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD. BY WHICH THEY
ARE TASKED TO ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE ABLE TO
EXERCISE THEIR FULL RIGHTS
UNDER THE LAW PARTICULARLY AND
MANY RELATE TO THEIR RIGHT TO
APPEAL WITHOUT THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO DO SO BECAUSE WE HAVE
DIFFICULTY HEARING OFTEN WHAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING WILL HAVE
GARBLED COMMUNICATION LINES
WILL DROP FACT ACROSS. HIS
BIRTH ARE EXPONENTIALLY
EXACERBATED SICK. BETWEEN THE
HAVES AND HAVE NOT IN OUR
SYSTEM WE STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION TO HOLD OFF
UNTIL THE END OF THE BARGAIN
THAT MAKE AND THE EXPIRATION OF
THE EXACT EMERGENCY ORDER
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS EQUAL
ACCESS TO JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH
MODERNIZING TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENT IF. YOU THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. MISTER NO ELSE IS
THE THEY WISH TO SPEAK FOR
LET'S BRING THAT THE BACK TO
MIKE. IN THE CHAIN. CALL ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
CENTER NEWMAN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER BACK. THANK YOU MISTER
ISSUE SENATOR BYRD IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND. A RESPONDING TO
THE LAST WITNESS FROM YEAR YOU.
WOULD BE GRATEFUL. FOR BUT I
THINK THAT THERE ARE. IMPORTANT
CONCERNS THAT ARE RAISED ON ONE
FOR THE CONCERN IS COST AND- IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT EVERYONE HAVE
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU ARE A
DEFENDANT UNLAWFUL DETAINER
ACTION. THAT YOU BE ABLE TO
PRESNT A DEFENSE WITHOUT IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY USED WITHOUT REGARD
TO COST NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO
IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY BEING
USED IN THE COURT- TO THE
EXTENT THAT. A LAWYER. IS A
PROPONENT OF EITHER A WITNESS
OR EVIDENCE AND THAT TECHNOLOGY
FAILS THEN. IT'S THE LAWYER
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR MAKING
SURE THAT HE OR SHE HAS AN
ACCURATE RECORD THE LAWYER
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE MAKE SURE
THAT EVIDENCE COMES IN SO USING
THE EXAMPLE BECAUSE STARTING A
RECORDS STILL NEAR RECORD IS
REALLY A MINISTERIAL WITNESS.
ALL OFTEN THE STIPULATIONS BUT
SOMETIMES NOT CAN TAKE QUITE A
LONG TIME TO GO THROUGH RECORDS
AND AUTHENTICATE THEM. IF THE
TECHNOLOGY FAILS AND YOU DECIDE
YOU'RE GOING TO USE REMOTE
ACCESS TO PROVIDE THAT. THAT
TESTIMONY AND YOUR RECORDS
DON'T COME IN THEN YOU'VE GOT A
PROBLEM THE NEAR SIDE. IS A IS
AT A LOSS AND YOU REALLY CAN'T
ASK FOR A CONTINUANCE SO YOU
CAN BRING THAT WITH THIS IN A
LIVE. OR YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO RESORT TO SOME OTHER METHOD
OF APPROVAL. BUT ARE SIMPLY
SAYING THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
USE TECHNOLOGY FOR SOMETHING
AGAIN LIKE A MINISTER A
WITNESS- THAT THAT. IT IS NOT A
SOLUTION THAT DOES NOT CREATE
EFFICIENCIES IN THE COURT IN
FACT IT IS COUNTER. OUR EFFORT
CREATE A FISHING SEES- AND THE
CROSSINGSIN THE COURTS. I
APPRECIATE THAT HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND. TO HER LAST POINT-
EGGMAN CASE TO PURPOSES YOU
KNOW WHAT'S THE RUSH WHY NOT
WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES RESULT. OF I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY REASON
TO WAIT AGAIN IF YOU'RE COUNCIL
AND YOU'RE GOING TO RELY ON A
REMOTE MASTERED TO. INTRODUCE
EVIDENCE AND IT FAILS THEN
YOU'VE GOT TO RESORT TO AN
ALTERNATIVE METHOD I THINK BY
AND LARGE IT'S WORK FINE I'M
SURE THRE ARE EXAMPLES OF
WHERE IT DIDN'T WORK FINE WHEN
YOU'VE HAD TO EITHER. DELAY OR
YOU HAD TO BRING IN A LIVE
WITNESS. BUT JUSTICE HERE MOST
OF THE TIME THE TECHNOLOGY
WORKS FINE. AND NINE OF MY LAST
QUESTION I GUESS AS YOU RESPOND
TO CERTAIN FEATURES SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES GOT. SIMILAR LETTERS
BUT I'M A QUOTE FROM ONE SB TWO
FORTY ONCE LANGUAGE JUST
WELCOME TO UNLICENSED.
UNAUTHORIZED FOREIGN
CORPORATIONS WITH OPEN ARMS TO
CONTINUE TO DO BUSINESS AS
USUAL CALIFORNIA. UNTIL THE
PLAYING FIELD IN THEIR FAVOR
AND GOES AGAINST THE LAWS OF
THE LEGSLATURE PUT IN PLACE.
TO PROTECT THE CONSUMER. IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND YES. I THINK I
THINK THAT'S WITH RESPECT TO.
THE STATE COURT REPORTERS. AND
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
SAYS THAT YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A
COURT REPORTER WHOSE LICENSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BASICALLY VOUCHING. FOR THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE HEARING THE
CALIFORNIA'S COURT REPORTING
STANDARDS SOMEWHAT ANALOGOUS TO
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU- THE SOCI
LOCAL COUNCIL. YOUR COUNCIL
FROM ANOTHER STATE. YOU WANNA
APPEAR HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
STATE LOCAL COUNCIL FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. OF ONE BEING
FAMILIAR WITH LOCAL RULES BUT
TO THE COURTS LIKE IT BECAUSE
THEY'VE GOT A LOCAL THROAT TO
CHOKE AS IT WERE- AND SO YOU
THEN ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY FOR.
THE STATE COUNCIL SAME THING
HERE YOU GOT A COURT REPORTER
IN CHARGE THIS IS DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT EXISTS RIGHT NOW YOU
GOT A COURT REPORTER IN CHARGE.
WHO HAS RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THOSE OUT OF STATE ENTITIES
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO ONE IN
CHARGE THOSE OUT OF STATE IN
THESE IN AS THE COURT REPORTING
BOARD. EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
TESTIFIED THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. TERMS OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. THANK YOU
MISTER. SURVISCOR. I THINK THE
AUTHOR I- BY. STEVEN ABOUT
ADDRESSING EQUITY I FEEL LIKE I
IS PART OF INTENT OF THIS BILL
I WOULD JUST MORE CURIOUS THAN
ANYTHING TO ME FEELS LIKE
THAT'S A SUBSTANTIAL POSITIVE
IN MY MIND ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
RUN A- TO- YOU KNOW TESTIFIED
REMOTELY- BUT THE MAIN THRUST
THE BILL SEEMS TO BE ABOUT THE
REGULATION- AND THIS NEW- THE
BORDER NEW DIVISION. I'M JUST
WANT TO HAVE THOSE TWO THINGS
FIT TOGETHER. IN TERMS OF
ACCESS AND THEN TE REALLY
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE BILL ONE
PARTY IS WITH ROOM RESPECT TO
REMOTE ACCESS. AND IT BY THE
WAY IT DOES SO FOR THOSE WHO
ARE- NEARER POTENTIALLY
IMPOVERISHED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY AS WELL
NOT NEARLY AS EXPENSIVE AS
TRAVELING TO FOR EXAMPLE
COURTHOUSE FOR A SIMPLE HEARING
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS THE
OTHER PART OF THE BILL- THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION PART OF THE
BILL IS IT THEN IT PLACES THOSE
COURT REPORTERS WHO ARE OUT OF
STATE- WITHIN THE JURISDICTION
OF CALIFORNIA'S AUTHORITY BY
VIRTUE OF THE COURT REPORTER IN
CHARGE. NO REPRESENTATIVE.
HELLO EXHORTATIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. SEEING NO HANDS
WAVING AND NO MICROPHONES UP
CENTER A BIRD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE URGEN IDLE THANK YOU.
RIVER MOTION ON SENATE BILL TWO
FOUR ONE. SIX OF THE CEREMONY.
YOUR TIME IN THE SUN TODAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
TWELVE SENATE BILL TWO FOUR ONE.
DO OU PASSED AS AMENDED THE
FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY RALPH ON
ROTH AYE MELENDEZ. ARCHULETA I
URGE A LOT AYE BEATS AYE FEATS
AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE DODD. DODD
AYE A HI AND I TADO LINE
FURTADO I'D HI JONES HI LEAVE
AT ON LEAVE I ME IN LINE MAN HI
NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE AYE CHOI
BOGUE HI BUT CHAU ABOAGYE HAND
BY HAND HI. WE HAVE- THE BILL
HAS THIRTEEN VOTES SUFFICIENT
TO MOVE OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK OU MISTER
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR.
BLOODS- OPEN THE ROLES. FIFTY
FILE ITEM ONE SB SIX OH THREE.
MELENDEZ. EIGHT DADA DODD AYE
HER TADO. JONES LEYVA LEYVA HI.
I CAN HEAR YOU WANT. WOULD YOU
WANT YOUR WITHOUT. THE BILL HAS
NINE. FIVE VOTES NO NO VOTES
THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM
THREE SB FIFTY NINE MELINDA'S
BEATS HER TADO JONES. LEYVA
LEYVA HI. MELENDEZ ONE DOES I.
BATES HI. WHAT WILL. TWELVE
ZERO LEVELS OUT. FILE ITEM FOR
SB SIX TO FIVE BEATS. BATES HI
HER TADO HER TADO II LEYVA
LEAVE A I. FOURTEEN ZERO THE
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM SIX SENATE
BILL FIVE THREE FOUR BEATS.
BATES HI BACKER. BAKER I HER
TADO. HER TADO II THE BILL HAS
FOURTEEN VOTES THAT'S OUT.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN BATES. BAIT NO
BACKER. SORRY FILE ITEM EIGHT
SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN BY SENATOR
LIMóN. HI BACKER I HER TADO
HER TADO BY THIRTEEN ONE OF
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NINE
SENATE BILL. ONE ZERO TWO.
CURRENT VOTE. SIX FIVE SEVEN NO
ARCHULETA. THIRTY THE BILL. SIX
FIVE SEVEN. KNOWS THE BILL
FAILS RECONSIDERATION GRANTED.
FILE ITEM TEN SB FIVE TO FOUR
CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN TWO ZERO
MELENDEZ. BETH JONES. ELEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM TWELVE SENATE BILL TWO
FOUR ONE CURRENT BOTH THIRTEEN
TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. IT I. WAS
IN. THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL AS A.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDAS SO
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOU CAN COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS AS ALWAYS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE. YOUR TESTIMONY AND
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS TODAY.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.